Bis zum nächsten Mal.
erster in vor ich da wobei ist das nicht eigentlich logischerweise immer so also
egal ob ich sage oder nicht ich weil ich muss ja als erstes da sein irgendjemand
muss ja den streamern machen ich denke mal was da stimmt nicht du bist nicht
zweiter guck mal du bist mindestens vierter ich bin erster common sense ist
zweiter, Lucky Luke ist
dritter und du bist vierter. Der Alfred
ist fünfter.
Gleich kommt da Michael 50 Billiarden
rein und fragt, ob er neue
Subscription
Badges, ob ich endlich
die neuen Subscription Badges
bestellt hab.
Moin.
Oh.
Feudai, du wurdest heute
wurdest du outmaneuvered
hier von Common Sense. Der war
zuerst da.
Hast du dich bei mir reingehackt?
Wie, jetzt? Hast du jetzt erst gemerkt, oder wie?
Ich dachte, das ist allgemein bekannt.
Drohnenpilot hatte was dagegen.
Fliegt da nix, wenn irgendwie einer am Flughafen mit einer Drohne drüber fliegt, oder so?
So Security, sicherheitsmäßig.
dann da alles eingestellt.
Das wird aber teuer für den
Drohnenflieger-Man,
wenn die den Flugverkehr einstellen müssen, deswegen.
Das wird aber verdammt teuer
für den Typ, wenn sie den erwischen.
Das wird teuer, aber richtig,
Mann.
Falls sie den erwischen.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht so einfach.
Twitch backt auf dem Desktop auch, wenn man den Tab nicht zumacht, steht dann manchmal
auch da, dass es seit einem Tag online ist und so ein Blödsinn.
Muss es googeln, was deployen bedeutet und was sagt Google?
ich finde es gar nicht so einfach in in einen satz zu packen was die plänen bedeutet also
ich habe das immer noch her ich würde ich würde sagen die plänen bedeutet eine anwendung
bereitstellen so mal ganz grob gesagt oder wie würdet ihr die plänen beschreiben das hat ein
google gesagt fliegerbert die fliegt bereitstellen ich meine genau genommen
heißt wahrscheinlich einfach nur bereitstellen aber es ist eigentlich
immer eine anwendung gemeint die da bereitgestellt wird
Nein, das ist falsch.
Sebi, das ist verkehrt.
Deployen heißt eigentlich nur, dass man eine Anwendung bereitstellt.
Ob das was das ist, ist ziemlich egal.
Ja, siehste mal.
War ich doch mit aus der Ärmel geschüttelten Definition gar nicht so verkehrt, oder?
Man kann auch einen ganzen Server deployen.
Also Chico konnte auch richtig gut was deployen.
Mehrfach am Tag.
die kation hatte mehrere deployment stellen bei mir im haus
schick hatte mindestens drei klos die hatte unten ein unter der treppe stehen der hat hier
oben in dieser abstellkammer ein klo stehen gehabt und sie hatte einen im hof auf der terrasse
und dann ist er bestimmt auch noch ins blumenbeet oder so gegangen wahrscheinlich hat die noch viel
mehr gehabt von denen ich nichts wusste das hast das hast ach so chat gpt ich wollte sagen das hast
du das hast du schön gesagt aber das ist chat gpt copy paste also chat gpt sagt wenn ein programm
entwickelt wurde läuft es meistens erst lokal beim entwickler er ist zu hoffen
zumindest mal deployment ist der schritt bei dem diese software auf eine
produktionsumgebung zum beispiel ein server eine cloud plattform oder direkt
auf endgeräten gebracht wird damit nutzer sie verwenden können ja das hat
also chat gpt hat es natürlich wieder chat gpt typisch aufgefüllt mit worten
bringt was die ploffers
also also ich finde ich finde die schönste umschreibung die ich vor ein paar jahren
gehört habe als obama noch präsident war als als beschreibung für warme auf dem klo war den
obama ins weiße haus setzen was ich auch letzten sinne video gehört habe ist den
den braunbären nach darmstadt bringen
aber obama ins weiße haus setzen ist für mich so ist das finde ich ist die beste
beschreibung da muss man erst mal kurz nachdenken ja ja
No Deploy Friday.
Also offiziell gibt es das nicht.
Inoffiziell würde ich sagen, macht es aber halt so gut wie keiner am Freitag.
Wir haben aber auch schon Sachen deployed am Freitag.
By the way, eines meiner Lieblingssachen zum Thema Deployment,
was in letzter Zeit passiert ist, noch gar nicht so lange her,
habe ich glaube ich mich auch auf Twitter ein bisschen lustig drüber gemacht.
ne, morgens in unserem Daily
Daily Stand-Up
was eigentlich
halt Remote ist und keiner steht, aber
Daily Scrum
Daily Stand-Up Scrum Stand-Up
wie auch immer man es nennen mag
ähm
warte mal, ich krieg's jetzt gar nicht, ich hab's auf Twitter geschrieben
ich krieg's gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen, es war sinngemäß
so, irgendeiner meinte so
hier Max, können wir das heute
irgendwie in Produktion
machen? Oder in Integration
machen ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau und da sagt ja das kann man machen ich bin bis keine ahnung 15 uhr da
sagt einfach bescheid
ganzen tag über hat sich keiner gemeldet bei mir und irgendwann
1530 habe ich dann im zug gesessen auf einmal klingelt mein telefon max der cluster hat zu wenig ressorts kommt nicht mehr hoch
Habe ich mir auch gedacht
So haben wir aber groß noch im Daily gesagt, ja, ja, das packen wir bis 15 Uhr.
Kein Problem, kein Problem.
Das ist auch der Klassiker, oder?
Klassik, ja.
Machen wir Doc Ploy mit Gitzor...
Mit was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Ich hab Dogploi noch nie verwendet
Ich hab Dogploi, ich hab das nur jetzt total oft
In letzter Zeit auf Reddit
Gelesen
Und da dachte ich mir, wir gucken uns das Ganze mal an
Ich mach mal kurz mein Linux VM an
Und wir brauchen eine Debian Kiste
Ach guck mal, da können wir doch eigentlich gleich
Unsere Omachi Kiste verwenden
Die schmeißen wir weg und dann ist ja ein Debian drauf
So machen wir das
Rename
Debian
Stockploi
So, aber jetzt machen wir erstmal hier
die Streaming
vor allem, was ist mit dir los?
Die Streaming vor allem an.
Hab nur 2 Minuten
Doku gescrollt und gesehen, dass du da auch deine
Git-Reposter direkt anbindest.
Ja gut, anders macht es ja auch keinen Sinn.
Irgendwo muss ja der Sourcecode für die Anwendung liegen.
Ah gut, CD.
Getestet.
Haha
Wo plus punkt tv ago was wir haben das sogar im stream gemacht
Ich glaube hier hier in einem der streams haben agro cd gemacht
Vermutlich für vermutlich kuba nettes geht ob es frei fährt
Da ist doch der Argo CD, seh ich doch direkt
Haben wir sogar schon im Stream gemacht
Vor zwei Jahren
Siehste mal, wie Bleeding Edge top aktuell
Wir wieder gewesen sind
Nein, das hab ich noch nicht gesehen
Ich les so Sachen auf Reddit auch nicht
Konntest du deine Omachi Frage beantworten?
Welche?
Welche Omachi
Frage?
Zockst du noch ab und an was?
Ja
Ich spiel ab und zu auf dem Private Server
WoW
Ähm
Ich spiel tatsächlich
Ab und zu noch ein bisschen Battlefield 3
Classic, ja
Manchmal spiele ich noch ein bisschen Diablo 2
Wobei ich in letzter Zeit eher
Project Diablo 2 spiele
Das ist ein Diablo 2 Mod
Auf dem alten
Client
Ansonsten sieht man jetzt hier nichts
Und auch ein paar kleine Sachen von Steam
Best of Exile 2
Habe ich gespielt, habe ich aber wieder uninstalled
gerade kein Kreisel-Crime, ne
achso, der
naja, also
ich kann den Hype immer noch nicht verstehen
ja, ja, Turtle Wow
spiel ich, also ich kann den Hype
um Omo Machi immer noch nicht so richtig verstehen
so, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es da schon
projekt für gibt es gibt ja mittlerweile diese ich weiß gar nicht wie man diese sorte software
nennt also da hast du irgendwie gedöns auf deiner linux kiste installiert so cloud oder sowas oder
cloud oder wie spricht man das überhaupt aus und da sagst du dann hier fix oder hier keine hand
kannst du gehst du in den github repo rein dass hier ich möchte gerne dass das ding auch w als
command command line ausgabe haben kann bitte erstellen wir dieses feature und macht einen
pull request auf github auf clod clod und dann tippt das für dich die kommandos ein für die
github cli und pull request zu erstellen und sonst was also theoretisch ist das tatsächlich möglich
sowas mittlerweile. Du könntest
da, also ich hab das persönlich noch nicht ausprobiert,
aber du könntest da theoretisch schon sagen,
erstelle mir eine Hallo World App
mit einem Slash-APN-Punkt,
der Hallo World als JSON zurückgibt
und dann benutze
ja, was ist es, GCloud
CLI
um
irgendwie per
Cloud Run das
zu deployen oder so.
Und dann musst du halt hoffen, dass es funktioniert und
du nicht 30.000 Euro Rechnung bekommst.
aber das kann also von der idee her funktioniert das heute schon wir müssen
debian installieren und wisst ihr auch warum wir debian installieren müssen
weil der vm champ nicht mehr funktioniert sonst hätte ich den vm champ
genommen aber der vm champ ist kaputt
debian download ich habe ewig kein debian mehr so manuell runtergeladen
keck
Wir probieren heute Docploi aus.
Guck hier, Docploi.
Da hast du quasi so ein bisschen ein Interface wie bei den üblichen Cloud-Anbietern, wobei
cloud anbieter trifft es nicht so ganz so ein bisschen wie digital ocean oder
nee nee digital ausstellt was soll so ein bisschen wie was besser ist wird
kann dann aussprechen ist was ich mein bisschen wie was soll ist das oder oder
netlify oder sowas wurde quasi in webfront end hast und da kannst mit einem
klick quasi eine anwendung anlegen sagt hier ist der source code repo kannst du
im weiteren klick noch eine datenbank anlegen und dann richtet es für dich
quasi SSL-Zertifikate ein, startet deine Anwendung in einem Container, macht den DNS-Eintrag,
erstellt eine Datenbank, connectet es zur Datenbank und sowas. Also so stelle ich mir
das zumindest vor, ja, also ob das denn jetzt so wirklich funktioniert, das müssen wir
sehen, ja. Zumindest ist supported, habe ich hier gelesen, docs installation, supported
ist debian und jubantu
jubuntu
was für black magic ja mal gucken ob das wirklich so funktioniert
chat wollen kennt sich jemand aus mit tomcat 9
9 zu 10, 11 Migration, als ob ich die Konfig...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber wir müssen das auf der Arbeit auch gerade machen.
Glücklicherweise kriegen wir eine Anleitung geliefert, weil das wieder so ein ganz...
Leute, das muss ich euch erzählen, das ist typisches Business Enterprise Gedöns wieder.
Also, Linux Server von uns, stellen wir bereit für irgendein Tochterunternehmen,
da drauf, also für irgendein Tochterunternehmen hat da eine Anwendung drauf laufen,
Das heißt, wir stellen wirklich nur die Basis Linux-mäßig.
So, die Tochterunternehmen hat da eine Anwendung drauflaufen.
Diese Anwendung, die wiederum haben sie allerdings nicht selbst entwickelt.
Die kriegen sie von einem Drittanbieter entwickelt.
Und der Drittanbieter, der liefert nicht einfach nur die Anwendung aus,
der liefert die mit gebandelt mit einem Tomcat irgendwie aus.
So, das heißt, wir haben jetzt gesagt, Tomcat-Version bald nicht mehr supported,
Security-technisch bedenklich, sind da zum Tochterunternehmen gegangen.
Das Tochterunternehmen ist zum Anwendungshersteller gegangen.
Der Anwendungshersteller hat jetzt irgendein neues Paket gebaut, hat es an das Tochterunternehmen geschickt.
Die haben uns das geschickt.
Wir haben gesagt, aber das passt überhaupt nicht für Red Hat 8.
Dann wieder zurück zum Tochterunternehmen, dann wieder zurück zum Hersteller.
Und jetzt ist ihnen aufgefallen, das funktioniert gar nicht so.
Jetzt haben sie uns eine PDF-Anleitung geschickt.
die aber auch nicht direkt an uns ging das heißt wir können nicht direkt mit
dem hersteller reden sondern die haben das an das tochterunternehmen geschickt
da an die projekt managerin und die hat uns jetzt gefragt ob wir verstehen was
die in dem pdf geschrieben haben was eigentlich gemacht werden muss
logisch oder ob wir es lieben läuft es so
Erste Woche im neuen Job als Admin im Krankenhaus und direkt Erkältung nach zwei Tagen geholt.
Im Krankenhaus hast du, glaube ich, auch ein höheres Risiko für sowas, weil da sind ja potenziell auch mehr Leute krank.
Ja, Leute, es ist immer bei Statistiken, ne?
Das ist übrigens bestes Beispiel dafür, dass man aus Statistiken nicht zwangsläufig Ursache und Wirkung erkennen kann.
Die meisten Leute sterben im Krankenhaus.
Die Frage ist, ist es im Krankenhaus gefährlicher oder kommen die Leute ins Krankenhaus, weil sie eh schwer krank sind?
Also das kannst du anhand von so einer Statistik gar nicht genau sagen.
Ich meine, realistisch betrachtet ihr so, die Leute, die schwer krank sind, kommen ins Krankenhaus.
Aber, könntest du auch andersrum sagen.
Könntest du auch sagen, im Krankenhaus ist es einfach viel gefährlicher.
German Efficiency.
Ja, meine Gilde in Dark hieß so.
Meine alte Gilde in Dark hieß so.
German Efficiency.
Ja, das ist natürlich blöd.
Aber ganz ehrlich, gerade im Krankenhaus hast du auch Leute, die können es noch weniger gebrauchen,
jetzt zusätzlich zu ihrer Krankheit nochmal eine Erkältung zu kriegen.
Also insofern würde ich sagen, ist das doch schon sinnvoller, du kommst nicht auf die Arbeit?
Was sagt denn dein Chef dazu?
Eigentlich streng genommen hat er nichts dazu zu sagen.
Wobei, im Krankenhaus, die kennen ja gar nichts.
Da müssen ja auch Leute mit Corona arbeiten gehen, weil es zu wenig Leute haben.
Stimmt, hast recht, die meisten Leute werden im Krankenhaus geboren.
Das ist auch so.
Five Head, ja.
So, wir installieren mal einen Debian jetzt.
Debian Net Install.
Ach, guck mal, ich bin ja auch doof, Leute.
Ich bin so blöd.
Ich hätte das Debian ISO gar nicht runterladen müssen.
Ich hätte auch Netboot XYZ verwenden können.
Aber egal.
Jetzt haben...
Ups.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nicht Omachi.
Zack.
Aus damit.
Edit.
Ähm.
raus
debian
warte mal, wir sind schon bei debian 13
kann ich
Doc Ploy überhaupt, warte mal
Doc Ploy
wo ist denn die Docs
debian 12
Wir probieren das einfach mal aus.
Es wird schon funktionieren.
Wird schon funzen.
Hallo? Ich will von CD starten.
Blitz.
Das piepst ja auch Debian.
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Graphical Install.
Leute, das ist Premiere.
Ich habe noch nie Debian, glaube ich,
mit einem grafischen Overflash, also mit
einem grafischen Installer
installiert. Ist das neu?
Ich habe schon ewig kein Debian mehr
von Hand installiert, fällt mir auf. Ich benutze
meistens irgendwelche Cloud-Images,
die in ein paar Sekunden am Start sind.
So sieht das jetzt aus.
Da, guck an.
Choose Language.
Continue.
Germany.
Ah, nee, other.
europa germany bin ich bin verwirrt weil irgendwie kriegt es der db an installer
hin dass man hier in der liste suchen kann der windows installer kriegt es
nicht hin schwarze magie lokales ist okay tastatur layout german
doch läuft bestimmt auch in containern da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ob das alles in
containern läuft weil das selbst der container management macht ich mein pio theoretisch
funktioniert das kannst den docker socket mauten in den docker container aber das muss ja auch
irgendwie datenbanken professionieren können und so was ich habe keine ahnung ich habe so
nie ausprobiert doch play domain name denken wir uns meine eigene domain aus
bis später ja doch bleu punkt der ehemalige stand bei mir um bieten gut
chat punkt ajaja das optimale domain
hat man die domain name muss
root passwort 123456 ich sag's immer wieder das passwort ist so verbreitet das kann nicht
sein new user max max strong passwort 123456 123456
admin passt 123 auch gut ich würde es 1 2 3 4 5 6 schon besser
Use the largest continuous free space.
Give him.
Was?
Too small?
What?
Verarschen?
Ach so!
Da ist ja schon was drauf.
da ist so magie drauf ja genau hier geidet partitioning use use entire disk ja auch falls
in one partition ja ja das kann man hierfür machen das bin ich partitioning rights changes
Da ist noch Omachi drauf gewesen, ihr habt recht, Chat.
Lululululu.
Was ist das?
Nein.
Wave Race!
Irgendwie kam es mir bekannt vor.
Ich habe an etwas anderes gedacht.
Äh.
was if you wish to scan more media know package manager das die db an ort kein
proxy n8 n habe ich nicht soll ich also doch hab ich ich hab's mal irgendwann im
docker container installiert nicht gewusst weil ich damit großartig
anfangen soll
das ist so ein self hosted
ok es installiert das ist das mag ich an dem jahren dass sowas halt
standardmäßig das ist ja okay dass sie das abfragen ob du an irgendwie so einem
package statistik rahmen teilnehmen möchtest aber standardmäßig ist no
selected kann man nacht in selbsthausen ja ziemlich sicher dafür ist glaube ich
Das ist... Was?
Desktop Environment.
Ha! Lull.
Standard System Utilities.
Das ist gut.
SSH Server Standard Utilities.
Mehr brauchen wir nicht.
Mir läuft die Nase.
Bin mal gespannt.
ob Doc Ploy
was ist für mich.
Weil ich bastle ja öfters mal so kleine
Anwendungen und probiere das dann mal.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist das was.
Open VM Tools. Guck mal, wie schlau
der ist. Der erkennt, wir installieren in der VM
und installiert direkt Open VM Tools.
Richtig High IQ Installer.
Die Zukunft ist jetzt, Leute.
Da sind wir.
debian am start okay dann suchen wir mal kurz raus was das ding für eine ip
gekriegt hat ach so ip hat es die
was zum teufel hat das für eine ip
ich habe das netzwerk falsch eingestellt ich habe das netzwerk falsch eingestellt
bridge if down ms3
chat
wir sind ja unter dem jahren
So, was haben wir jetzt für eine IP gekriegt?
Noch keine.
Was?
Nämlich verarschen?
Warte mal, warte mal.
Warum kriegt man Debian keine IP?
Bridged? Bridged ist doch genau richtig.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
dhc client
ja super ich hab nix zum installieren
super
was mit mydebian los
das versteh ich jetzt nicht
mod probe
minus r pc speaker
haha
ähm was hat mydebian
dhc client haben wir nicht
bin ich jetzt irgendwie super verwirrt?
Hä?
Warum krieg ich, warum krieg ich diese komische
Auto-Select-IP?
Check ich's jetzt grad nicht?
Was hat das Ding für Schmerzen?
Ist das Checkish nicht?
Also mit IPs habe ich normalerweise nie Probleme in der VM.
Habe ich irgendwas verpasst?
Hä?
Chatkill?
Warum zieht sich das keine IP?
Ich glaube das ist irgendwie verbuggt.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Okay, wie geht das IP...
PC Speaker weg.
wie das ip address ich kann nur die fconfig so tags netz
utils oder so ich kenne die fconfig so tags ip address link ip adre linux set
ip-adress ip-adress at device ok ip-adress at at was hier
device e mp2 es 1 12 16 82 punkt okay gucken wir mal ob es frei ist eigentlich will ich dass
das ping 12 12 2.2 keine ahnung 230 okay das scheint frei zu sein 230 wie war das jetzt
jetzt hier trusted slach ihr def slash slash 24 def ok ping 192 1 1 2.1 50 das ding hat kein
netzwerkverbindung was ist das denn moment hat meine vm hier netzwerkverbindung ist ak
Der ist irgendwas kaputt, Leute.
Da ist irgendwas kaputt.
Da ist netzwerktechnisch was kaputt bei mir auf dem Host.
Ja, guck mal an.
Was ist das?
Hier.
Okay.
Ich wette mit dir.
Ich wette mit euch, das liegt daran, weil ich gestern Virtualbox installiert habe.
VM 0 ist Bridged.
Bridged 2. Ah.
Ah.
Ähm
Oh, wo bin ich
gerade angestöpselt?
Wait a minute, bin ich an 10
Gig oder an 2,5 Gig angestöpselt?
Äh
Moment
Network, wo sieht man das unter Windows mittlerweile
gescheit?
Control Panel
Äh
Hier, ich bin
angestöpselt an
Hier, Realtek, 2,5 Gig.
Der hat sich bestimmt gepritcht
an irgendein Virtual Box Interface.
100 Pro.
Pass auf, jetzt geht's gleich.
Ja
Geht immer noch nicht
Leute
Irgendwas ist hier gerade ganz
Hardcore
PP-Gar
Es geht
Es geht, das war das Problem
Warum die andere Kiste
Keine
Ah doch hier, passt doch
Hat's doch
Easy, okay das war das Problem
Dann rebooten wir nochmal
Und gucken was das Ding für eine IP kriegt
IP-Leak
Shit, ihr seid bestimmt schon drin
Oder jetzt zu spät
Zu spät
Jetzt kann man nichts mehr machen
Rootkit
Ist schon installiert
Jetzt haben wir 2.30
also da war mal ssh root at max wahrscheinlich oder max at 130
ok machen jetzt einfach keck keck wait wie war das strict house key checking no
okay
minus er auch das haben wir schon mal
jetzt immer auf unserer doch kiste per ssh drauf
Update
Erstmal neue Package
Wie? Wir sind top aktuell, Leute
Trixie
Warte mal, ist Trixie der
Der Dinosaurier bei Toy Story?
Ist das der Dinosaurier?
Warte mal
Was ist Trixie? Toy Story?
Toy Story
Ja, der Dinosaurier
dinosaurier
Nicht der T-Rex, den hatten wir auch schon. Der T-Rex, äh, der, ähm,
Triceratops ist das, ne? Triceratops.
Okay, so, ja dann können wir uns mal angucken, wie man das installiert. Doc Ploy.
schau mal also wir haben hier cpu kerne 16 gb und 50 gig ohne 50 gig festplatte sollte eigentlich
für testzwecke ausreichen schau mal beim leute wir können einfach als gut direkt was nach nach
so macht man es ist doch so ähnlich wie coolie fahr ich glaube schon ein
pylaster ja ein pylaster ist nice zum aufbauen und danach braucht man ihn nie
wieder want to skip installation process wie installieren wir peipen einfach
immer karl drauf ist ok dann installieren wir noch ein paar andere
Sachen, nämlich nochmal H-Top und D-Stats.
Abt hat eine neue
Ausgabe, wie ich sehe.
Und Abt ist deutlich schneller geworden. Oder liegt es
jetzt daran, dass es auf einer SSD läuft?
Mir kommt so vor, als hat Abt
richtig zugelegt.
Von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Fast so schnell wie Pac-Man.
Ne, wir müssen nicht rebooten.
Okay, jetzt können wir hier.
Bam.
So, was macht es hier für Dinger?
Certificates,
Upd, Install, Docker, CE,
Docker, CLI, Container,
IODock, okay.
Ich lasse es einfach machen.
Ich hätte vorher einen Snapshot machen sollen.
Vor der Installation.
installation
von der Debian Kiste
Wieso macht up schneller wenn es auf einer SSD läuft? Ja doch
Das Downloaden ist immer noch das langsamste aber wenn ihr dir mal beispielsweise bei Reta das Package Management angeguckt hast der rödelt teilweise
ewig rum nachdem er die Pakete runtergeladen hat
Und Up war vorher auch nicht gerade so das schnellste.
Repairing.
Service
P
Y
67P79C6XNLF8H385XAMFS6M
Genau mein Gedanke
Und der hat converged
Dadurch können wir aber froh sein
Der ja
Wo soll ich hingehen?
Habe ich gerade meine IP wieder mal geleakt?
Na klar.
Na klar, mal wieder IP-Leak.
Mal wieder IP-Leak.
Aber ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, Leute.
Das wird so nicht funktionieren.
wir müssen auf 2.130 3000 ja das sieht schon besser aus was will er mit meiner
public internet ip katnuppe
ok nette software der beste wenn ich jetzt nicht schlimm es sei denn die komischen den
DOSer sind wieder am Start.
Die hatten wir ja auch schon öfters am Start.
Deswegen versuche ich immer nicht unbedingt meine
IP zu linken.
Aber gut, ist
jetzt halt so.
Und jetzt?
Brauchen wir da wirklich eine echte E-Mail?
Ja, öffentlich
betreiben für
für
Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate und sowas
wahrscheinlich, ja.
Chat, vielleicht ist es doch besser,
wir
vielleicht machen wir das
auf einer Hetzner-Kiste.
Aber ich will das eigentlich gar nicht öffentlich betreiben.
Okay, Name, Max,
E-Mail,
omegalol
at cutechat.ai
Ich hoffe, der schickt nicht wirklich eine E-Mail.
Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Hochkomplexes Passwort.
123456789 123456789 willi fahrer nicht ausprobiert
okay das immer alles klar wir machen das mal kurz aus dem dark wieder raus dass das
geschalt aussieht so was kann man denn da jetzt machen projects monitoring schedules traffic files
ist was warum ach so weil er versucht letzten kopf zu machen sie nicht locker
swarm das ist auf docker swarm war gibt es wirklich jemand der noch swarm benutzt requests
web server setting domain war mal nene domain ist q chat punkt ja ja ja letzt ein crypt e mail
wir provision keine automatischen ssl zertifikate das brauchen wir jetzt nicht
die frage ist kann der dns kann der dns zertifikats gedöns machen mit
Let's Encrypt? Da muss es nämlich nicht
public stehen.
Ich hab nicht Type Let's Encrypt.
So, Web-Server,
Traffic, Reload,
Backup, egal.
Läuft das Ding jetzt in einem Docker
oder nicht?
Ja.
Da läuft ein Postgres,
Redis und ein Traffic.
Okay.
Es gibt einen neuen Swarm-Mode, wirklich?
Ich dachte, der Swarm ist outdated, overrated, cheap-baited.
AI, ganz wichtig.
You don't have any AI-Configurations.
Warum brauche ich AI da drin?
Git.
Create your first Git-Provider.
Git-Lab, Bitbucket, Gitti.
Gita, wie auch immer.
Da können wir einen installieren hier drauf, würde ich sagen.
weil wir brauchen ja wir brauchen einen git repo kram so projects werden mal eins
test project
und jetzt
production environment das finde ich gut wir haben nur ein environment
akku das quasi so eine art projektmappe und darin kann man jetzt notend what create service
Create Service, Data Application, aha!
Frontend oder Backend, nennen wir es mal.
Okay.
Aha!
Ach, select the source code of your project.
Okay, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall...
Ja, ja, okay.
Wir brauchen auf jeden...
Man kann auch einen Zip hochladen, okay.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall mal ein...
GTA noch.
GTA Docker.
Dragon's Out, schön, dass du am Start bist.
Warum machen die das so kompliziert?
Warum so kompliziert?
Gibt es da nicht was anderes?
Okay, I.O.
Da haben die doch bestimmt hier
One-Liner.
Rootless? Ich brauche das nicht.
Rootless.
Haben wir das nicht hier noch?
Warte mal.
GTA.
aber doch was geht lab equate was aber doch hier noch okay dann machen wir doch hier mal
ja keine ahnung docker ran der bestimmt nicht was ist der neueste container gta
125 latest 124 wir nehmen einfach 124 das ist vor 23 tagen ist schon okay
1 4 slash data so und wir mountain hat mein user eigentlich docker ps hat er nicht ja das
nochmal user in docker coop ach komm wir machen es einfach so wir sind ja der demian wir gehen
jetzt einfach nach etc passwd teufel ein wim drauf ok der daniel weiß bescheid da
den null beste genau das habe ich gesucht warum gibt es kein user mod
Nee, nee, das ist nicht jetzt...
Oh doch. Moment, das ist eine reine Sache.
Achso, das ist von der Espin.
Ah.
Max.
Gut.
Docker, PS, zack, bumm, da sind wir.
Okay.
Docker, run, home.
Machen wir hier mal ein Verzeichnis.
MKD, geht dir.
Home.
Max.
Ja.
Ne, Port 3000 können wir nicht machen.
Ähm, weil
auf Port 3000 läuft das andere schon.
Wir wollen auf
Port...
Ja, keine Ahnung.
3080.
Nach 3000.
Hab ich das jetzt richtig rumgeschrieben mit den Ports?
Ja, ne?
Docker PS.
Mein 22 wird auch...
22?
Achso, dass man da...
Ach stimmt, das braucht man ja auch.
Dass man über SSH klonen kann.
Ja, das wird natürlich jetzt ein bisschen schwierig.
Egal, schauen wir mal.
port 80 haben wir hier 122 1 6 2.1 30 punkt 3080 zack ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
alles gut
install
was ist das hier? peepo please musik
Okay, Username.
Root.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Achso.
Wait a minute.
Register now.
Warte mal.
Wie? Moment, Moment.
Default Password.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Where is the admin default password?
Change admin.
first account aha ok gut gut at cute chat 1 2 3 4 5 6 hoffentlich ist das jetzt erlaubt
jetzt die sind aber hartnäckig 123456789 1 2 3 4 5 7 die wollen mich alle beschützen vor schlechten
passwörtern account successfully created okay jetzt haben auch getriebe geht's
geht ins lokal laufen da hast du recht das können wir machen aber man kann
bestimmt http klonen man muss nicht über ssh klonen so create new repository
owner root repo name ja aber tests test app bla blubb great okay so dann legen wir legen jetzt
mal eine technik wir machen mal eine dotnet app ich war gespannt ob das ding dort netz kann da
bin ich mal gespannt ob das funst und komik marken wie gut das wirkung wie gut das ist
Ihr MKDeer
DocPloyChamp
Ähm
Wir installieren mal
.NET 10
Gerade schon dabei sind
Kommt das jetzt nicht auch demnächst
Irgendwann raus?
.NET 10 müsste ja doch jetzt eigentlich rauskommen
Leute
Wir testen, passt mal auf
Mein Plan ist
WordPad, ich weiß es nicht, warum WordPad, Max?
Wir testen eine Spring Boot App, wir testen eine .NET App, wir testen eine Go App und
den Rest könnt ihr euch aussuchen
Okay, .NET New
Web
.NET Rust, ach weiss ich nicht, come on Leute, muss das sein, ja, muss das sein
okay hier haben wir unsere app alles klar so und jetzt müssen wir das hier machen dass wir
unsere kamen pushen können ja geht in it geht geht geht einer master bei mir bleibt das weiter
so wie darf das weiter master heißen jetzt minus a geht kommt minus a omega
lol perfekt um schritt ich hätte vielleicht ein gt knorr reinlegen
sollen anstatt wurscht zum testen reicht das zack was master root was der hut
eine 12345789 beim aber unsere anwendung gepusht so und jetzt hat die haben auch
ein ziel ein jetzt kann man das ganze hier klonen in in doc ploy die pläne
singe you need to confirm account of go to settings ok ich geht leiblich
verklickt gta
gut ist 1 2 1 2 1 30 30 80 redirect urlaub client id klein secret muss ich da jetzt ein
Go to your gta settings navigate to applications create new oauth 2
Wo ist das problem?
ATTPS, Alter.
Lul.
Äh.
Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Create new
OAuth 2 Application.
Create new OAuth 2 Application
Name. Äh, Doc Ploy.
Warte mal, was soll ich
redere?
Ich bin nicht so ganz sicher, was ich da mache, aber...
Da ist nichts confidential.
Okay.
Okay, Client ID.
Ich habe absolut keinen Plastenschimmer, was ich hier mache, aber es ist schon mal eine gute Anleitung.
Secret Configure.
Der will unbedingt HTTPS machen.
Ah, hier HTTPS. Das ist ja Fail.
Beste, warum habe ich HTTPS reingeschrieben? Ich kack, Noob.
Äh.
Nein, äh.
Äh
So geht das anscheinend nicht
Ich hab...
Mach den Confidential-Haken wieder rein.
Okay.
Stand es da?
Aha.
Meinst du, das war der Confidential-Haken?
Oder ich hab's einfach falsch gemacht?
Was auch immer.
Es hat anscheinend funktioniert.
Okay, und jetzt?
Test Projects, Backend.
Jetzt hier GTA URL, Select...
Ah!
Ach, guck mal, der geht über die API.
Man kann das hier direkt auswählen.
Braucht gar keine URLs mehr copy-pasten.
Das ist schön, das gefällt mir.
Branch, Master,
Build Pass, Slash.
Ah, da brauche ich bestimmt einen Docker-File, oder?
Ohne Docker-File wird das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Save.
Ach hier, Nixpacks.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Static.
Docker-File.
Okay.
Ja, ja, ja.
Finde ich cool.
Was ist Railpack?
Hat irgendjemand einen Plan, was Railpack ist?
Railpack.
Wann?
Okay.
Was ist Railpack?
Es gibt wirklich jeden Tag tausend neue Tools, gell?
Zero-Config-Application will then automatically analyze your code and turns it into an image.
Okay.
Hat schon mal nicht so viele.
Ist das Ruby?
Nee, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass das Ruby ist.
Das sieht ein bisschen nach Go aus, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Ja, ist es auch.
Get started.
Kann kein .NET bilden.
Outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Okay, das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt ein Docker-File in unserer Anwendung,
dass das Ganze laufen kann.
Dann bauen wir doch mal ein Docker-File.
Es gibt doch ein offizielles...
dotnet asp.net docker file ja im docker file from docker file asp.net da gibt es
doch eins mixpack mein problem ist ich habe kein
plastenschimmer wie mixpack funktioniert
containerisieren ja genau ich will einfach nur wissen wie das image heißt
image please image logger file hier genau rom.net sdk gibt es da schon sdk
gibt es da schon sdk 10.0 es gilt wir können das mal kurz hier vom vm champ
abgucken stocker fall das ist doch der machte auch dort netz kram aber ich
glaube der macht ein bisschen andere anderen kram
werkt ihr slash app copy everything dort netz restore das ist immer ganz praktisch
ob jemand das mal was microsoft da macht
ach so das eine ist das bild im rest des anderen ist das runtime image macht sinn
macht sinn gibt es das gibt es das auch schon mit 10.0 ist der chef copy from
Okay, Docker-Bild.
Ich hoffe, ich habe nichts vergessen.
Vielleicht hätte ich das Ganze nochmal taggen sollen,
damit ich gleich starten kann.
Angeben und das war's.
Der macht das für dich.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Du meinst, ich klicke hier Nixpack an
und dann funzt das einfach?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Woher soll der wissen, dass man hier .NET bilden muss?
Ich mach das jetzt mal. Ich glaub dir aber nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Allows you to serve a single directory after the build phase.
Useful if final build has been served.
Mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Das wäre extrem die POC, wenn das funktioniert.
Okay und jetzt?
Save.
Deploy.
Are you sure you want to deploy this application?
Yes.
Wie, sag bloß, das funktioniert jetzt.
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das kann halt sein, dass das einfach funzt.
Ohne Docker-File und ohne alles.
Fuck, das...
Das checkt es ja wirklich.
Alter, das ist ja geil.
Das ist ja nice.
Boah, das ist ja richtig cool.
Ich hab zwar kein...
Haha.
Oh mein Gott.
Was ist das Problem?
Was, .NET 6 or lower?
Was?
Das ist bestimmt, weil es Preview ist. Kann das sein?
Kann das sein, weil ich eine Preview-Version nehme, die er noch nicht... das kann er noch nicht.
In dem Fall kannst du in den Env eine andere Version angeben, dann zieht er sich die.
Okay.
Das ist ja mega nice.
Äh, Env, du meinst hier?
Hier drinnen meinst du, oder wo?
Und dann sag ich was?
Nix Packs, die Sharp SDK Version?
Gleich 10.0.
Aber das ist Preview.
Das kann der wahrscheinlich noch nicht.
Aber trotzdem, probieren wir mal.
Deploy.
Hau ein.
Stop.
Confirm.
Deploy.
Ich lese immer den Chat.
Chat.
Ich kann aber nicht nur Chat lesen.
Oh.
Okay, das kann er noch nicht.
Kann das sein, dass das noch nicht geht?
Weil das, ähm...
Okay, wir wollen jetzt mal nicht unfair sein.
Wir machen da mal ein .NET 9 Projekt raus.
Weil .NET 9 ist schon raus, .NET 10 ist noch nicht raus.
Ich glaube, der kann das einfach nicht.
Moment mal, nix. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was nix packs ist.
C-Sharp.
Und woher weiß man jetzt, was der alles unterstützt?
Okay, wir sind mal fair.
Wir sind mal fair.
und sagen mal...
Aber in den Dokus steht nichts drin,
was der unterstützt.
Guck, mehr gibt es dazu nicht.
Probieren wir nur 10 an,
statt 10.0.
Okay.
Wollen wir mal?
View.
Und, was lädt er sich?
Irgendwas runter?
Oh, da hängt es jetzt.
Ah, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay, das kann er nicht.
C-Sharp bekommt wohl
keine Liebe, ja.
Aber schau, ich hab wirklich
nix Packs.
C-Sharp.
Wenn wir .NET in Nixpacks haben.
Okay, das interessiert mich in der Tat.
Bitte seht diese Docks.
8.0.0 muss man machen?
Moment.
10.0.0?
So vielleicht.
Ansonsten machen wir ein Docker-File.
Okay, Docker-File geht auf jeden Fall.
Ah, shit.
Undefinedvariable.net
SDK 10.
Okay, wir sind mal fair.
Das 10er ist drin.
Aber da hat er auch gesagt, gibt es nicht.
Das ist sogar das Aktuelle.
Ja.
Muss ich vielleicht, muss ich vielleicht
Aber guck mal, der sagt doch, dass das hier nicht gefunden wird
.net SDK
.net minus SDK underscore 10, findet er nicht
Ne, er wollte underscore holen
Okay, ganz ehrlich
Das ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen
Ein bisschen zu viel
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Nixpacks
wir benutzen eine Beta-Version
oder eine
Release-Candidat-Version.
Ich probiere das jetzt einmal noch so aus.
Wollte eigentlich
das hier kopieren.
Nee, nee, so.
Ich mache da mal eine .NET 9-Version.
Hat Nixpack etwas mit Nixpackage?
ich glaube schon ich habe keinen plan was das ist ich habe nie benutzt kommt
neude wir machen das mal anders wir machen jetzt
ich speichere mir das docker fall hier mal kurz und dann
Jetzt sagen wir .NET new Web.
Das normale .NET 10 machen wir jetzt.
.NET run.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt automatisch bildet, wenn man dann da pusht.
ok geht kommit omega lol beste geerdet an e-kit bin und objekte die bag will ich ehrlich gesagt
auch gar nicht enden push gut 1 2 3 4 5 sie macht 9 so hat er das jetzt gleich auch gecheckt dass
wenn hier neu gepusht haben.
Okay, oder?
Domains, Deployments.
Was ist denn hier?
Cancel Queues.
Okay, also er hat noch nicht gecheckt, dass das...
Ist das denn hier in meinem
Git angekommen?
Now.
Ja.
Reload.
Jetzt gehen wir hier in Environment
und sagen hier
9.0.0
Save.
Oder wir lassen es mal raus.
Mal gucken, ob es automatisch checkt.
Deployments.
Deploy.
Wenn nicht, machen wir es im Docker-File.
Da ist eine Autodeploy-Option.
Ah.
Ist sie jetzt an oder aus?
Die ist an, oder?
Okay, und da können wir jetzt .NET 9 angeben.
Ja, das ist
UI-Design ein bisschen fail.
Normalerweise würde ich sagen,
links ist das Ganze an, aber
es sieht so eher an aus.
Keine Ahnung.
Wenn es jetzt nicht geht,
machen wir Docker-File, Leute.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert.
Okay.
Is there an existing issue for this?
zu 7.0 nee
ich downgraden bis bestimmt nicht minus ja hier ein nix packs nutzt eine mix
package commit von 2023 ich habe mich kann aber nicht auslesen
nix auswählen oder?
But the current
NixOS Package Archive is very outdated.
This is how you can
add the latest archive and actually
get .NET. Aha!
Nix packs Tommel.
Where do I add this?
ok da gibt es ein settings irgendwie für die für die die frage ist wo settings
nix pecks tommel doch ploy
doch bloß
das ist schwachsinn oder
bei adding nix pecks tommel fall to your repository
repository und kann kasten meister feine docker mit ach so eine eine nix packs tommel und da kann
man auch die neueste version dann eintragen ich teste das erst mal mit dem was die hier haben
jetzt wird es aber advanced advanced also brauchen wir hier quasi eine nix packs wie ist das ding
nix packs tommel okay das ist dann doch ein bisschen viel auf aufwand wenn das so outdated
ist aber das macht ja nichts
nix packs tommel ich hab dachte ich hab mir das irgendwie
Okay.
Commit.
Git add
nixpux.
Wir machen einfach git add
minus a. Committen wir halt irgendwie
einen Scheiß, aber macht ja nichts.
Gut. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9. Bam.
Also das Auto-Deployen
funktioniert noch nicht. Die Frage ist halt auch, hat mein
Auto-Deploy denn wirklich funktioniert?
Was noch
cool wäre, wenn man hier irgendwie sehen kann, was
für eine Version
quasi hier
ausgewählt, also ne, ne, ne, nicht Version,
was für ein
Comet hier
gerade gebildet
ist.
Deploy.
Confirm.
Schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Ja, anscheinend geht das mit
Doc Ploy irgendwie nicht.
Aber schauen wir mal.
Ah!
Da gucke ich mal an.
Das funzt
Okay, ganz ehrlich, der Vorteil von Nixbills
Gegenüber einem Docker-File wäre jetzt nur
Wenn das wirklich out of the box funzt
Ich hab jetzt mal eine blöde Frage
Ich hab mich mit Nixbills noch nie beschäftigt
Warum ist das besser als ein Docker-File?
Weil es automatisch geht, oder?
Wenn es geht
jetzt läuft es ist einfacher ja also wenn es wenn man das nicht konfiguriert so angeblich
läuft die anwendung jetzt oder woher weiß ich das denn jetzt ob die anwendung läuft
angeblich läuft die anwendung hier angeblich läuft jetzt was projects backend
Und wie komme ich da jetzt drauf?
Open in Terminal.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Also Deployments hat...
Ah, wie komme ich jetzt auf die Anwendung drauf?
privi deployments domains aber brauchen nur domain gibt es nicht so was wie import oder so dass das
macht natürlich sinn es läuft auch es läuft auch gar nicht also richtig ein eisfunst was
woher weiß ich denn jetzt ob die anwendung richtig läuft loks
loks v
app launch fehlt
not found
You must install the Net to run this application
Okay, Leute
Wir machen einen Dockerfile
Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob
Ja, ist jetzt Autodeploy an oder aus?
Jack, erklärt mir mal
Jetzt ist es an, oder?
Ist es jetzt an?
Ich würde sagen, jetzt ist es an
Watch... Watchpath.
Ein was? Ah!
Ach so!
Oh!
When files in this path change,
a new deployment will be triggered.
Ja gut, äh...
Alles, oder?
Zurzeit.
Na, wobei,
nee, nee, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ähm, ja doch,
Programmed CS.
Wenn Programmed CS changed.
Weil wir haben da aktuell nicht.
Okay, alles klar.
Ähm,
dann bauen wir jetzt ein Docker-File.
locker feil ich habe es mir doch irgendwo zwischen gespeichert
also das müsste eigentlich so passen würde ich sagen
ne .NET 9 wollen wir haben. .NET Docker DLL, ne das heißt wahrscheinlich dann anders,
sondern schauen wir mal. Docker build .-tag temp 0w.
Schauen wir mal.
Container gebildet.
Erstmal 3000 Sachen runterladen.
Das halbe Internet.
Wird gesaugt.
Warning found.
Der beschwert sich,
dass das nicht groß geschrieben ist.
Ups.
Es ist nur .NET
So
Docker
Run
Minus RM, so findest du das doch
Command could not be loaded
Ja klar, weil das Ding auch nicht so heißt
Das Ding heißt, wie heißt meine DLL
Die dann am Ende rauskommt
Bin
Dog Ploy Champ DLL
Bild
Eigentlich könnte ich es überschreiben
Ha, da läuft es
Okay
Sehr gut, jetzt haben wir einen Docker-File
Dann machen wir das mit einem Docker-File
Kann man da mehrere
Ah, guck mal
Wenn es Dockerfile sich geändert hat
Will ich auch, dass es
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Jetzt sagen wir hier
Dockerfile, path of your Dockerfile
Path ist Punkt, oder?
Das kann man bestimmt rauslassen
Nee
Dockerfile, das heißt einfach nur Dockerfile
ok so und jetzt geht status geht es komm mit push schauen ob der automatischen
bildträger aber das kapiert hat die pläne hat er nicht kapiert
wahrscheinlich habe ich jetzt ausgeschaltet auto deploy oder
aber das hat er das hat funktioniert noch nicht mit dem auto deploy
ok deploy running ok jetzt lädt er sich die ganzen docker container und macht zeug
Ich habe was geändert.
Das Docker-File habe ich geändert.
Docker deployed.
Zack.
Logs.
Haha.
Jetzt funzt es auch.
Und jetzt brauche ich Domains.
Okay.
Add Domain.
Ähm.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Test App
.qchat.ajaja
Ich muss mal kurz auf meinen Router
die DNS umbiegen.
IP
DNS
Static
Add New
reg ex und a ja ja auf 1 202 130 blei
doch schauen ob das jetzt funst das müsste jetzt wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe auflösen dick
Testapp.
QChat.
Ayaya.
At
1.1.2.50
Ja, Fonst.
Löst richtig auf.
Okay.
Ne, ne, ne.
Was ist denn eine
Traffic.me Domain?
ist ein magischer domain der pro wald hat die ns vor any ip-adress
aha
und wie von stars ich muss ja ich muss doch ja den dns server eintragen oder
gut ich habe es jetzt ja immer ein router eingetragen das passt also
post ok test app chat punkt er path slash internet container port
checkt er das nicht automatisch
Wir machen mal hier Create.
Domains resolve to us.
Nein!
Soll es nicht.
Und kannst du mal aufhören, meine Public IP überall hinzuschreiben?
Bad Gateway.
jeder port der port stimmt nicht locks a 80 80 muss sich domains 80 80 update
kann man es jetzt für herr wald ist funst
demnächst ein vp es ist ja nicht schlimm wenn die wenn die ip geleakt wird außer
die DDoS-Typen sind wieder am Start.
Funst!
Ihr könnt alle
bei mir im Main baden, ja.
Okay, das irgendwie hatte schon was
Nices, oder?
Open Terminal,
Funst ist jetzt auch, okay.
Let's dead. Aber nicht,
im Container ist nichts drin.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, ist, wie das
mit dem Autodeploy funktioniert.
Nee, nee, nee, bis jetzt haben wir noch lange nicht alles angeguckt.
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal...
Sternchen, Sternchen, wir watchen einfach alles.
Safe.
So, und jetzt...
Mein Problem ist immer noch, Leute, ich check nicht, ob das an oder aus ist.
Also ich würde sagen, Chat, was meint ihr?
Clean Cache ist aus, Auto Deploy ist an, oder?
Umgedreht.
Ja, gut.
Do you want to start this application?
Ja, irgendwie.
Läuft doch schon.
Start.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Application started.
Ja, war es doch vorhin schon.
Was ist, wenn ich sage Stopp?
Geht es dann nicht mehr?
Ruhm aus.
Bad Gateway.
Okay, macht Sinn.
Start.
Hello World.
Okay, Funs.
ok also dann nächstes wir probieren mal wenn ich jetzt hier drin irgendwas ein
program cs so hello world hello chat ok so status git commit push
so und jetzt sollte er doch eigentlich checken dass es eine neue version gibt macht er aber nicht
nicht.
If you want to use this
URL in the config of your Git provider or
Docker. Ah.
Moment.
Da muss ich
irgendwas eingeben, ne?
Okay.
Ähm.
Äh, wie mach ich
denn das hier in Git, Git, Git,
Git, Git, Git,
äh,
ähm,
ähm, Settings,
Webhooks,
Add Webhook?
Äh.
Wie denn? Was denn?
Wie?
Warum muss ich da einen Service auswählen?
Isea-Doc-Ploy-Webhook
Aber...
Aber das ist doch falsch, oder?
Ja.
Moment, das ist genau das gleiche
Dann verstehe ich nicht, warum ich hier unterschiedliche Sachen auswählen kann
Das ist eigentlich egal, was ich auswähle
Target URL
Post
Custom Event
Push
branch filter master
kann man das einfach so triggern wenn ich das jetzt mal spaßeshalber hier aufrufe
kann ich jetzt sagen curl probieren wir mal ob das funzt post error deploying application
Error ist null. Geil.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
This action cannot be unannounced.
Will change to refresh token and other tokens will be invalidate.
Welche Tokens?
Minus Data.
Lul we.
Aber es scheint nicht zu funsten, weil mit Curl kann ich es nicht triggern.
Da geht es von GTA aus auch nicht.
Es könnte ein bisschen selbsterklärend sein.
Confirm. Okay.
Brauche ich nicht noch irgendeinen
Application Not For...
Achso, gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Eigentlich sollte das doch jetzt
triggern, wenn ich das jetzt...
Soll ich das einfach hinzufügen?
Add Webhook.
Gibt's nicht.
Kein Sch...
Tut nicht.
Ja doch, ich weiß bloß nicht, wo die
Authentifizierung ist.
Äh,
Dogploy Webhook.
Autodeploy.
Die URL ist neu.
Ah, ihr habt recht, Chat.
Ist das jetzt die richtige, die neue?
Ja.
Juckt ihn aber trotzdem nicht.
Äh.
Also.
Webhook, allow automatic deployer application
or everchaser made in your source repository.
Obtain Webhook URL.
Navigate to your repository.
Application JSON.
Das war's. Angeblich sollte es jetzt funktionieren.
Mach mal einen neuen Push.
Also wenn das hier schon entfunzt.
Ich finde übrigens auch geil, Error gibt es nicht.
Okay, machen wir mal einen Push.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Program CS.
Ausrufezeichen.
Komm mit.
Push.
Ja, bam.
Broken.
Gegen dich.
ich würde sagen mein auto deployment ist kaputt
wenn du runter scrollst siehst du die messages
wo was
blogs
Warum ist das Error Deploying Application?
Dock Ploy.
Achso, warum das failed?
Du meinst, wenn ich hier runter scrolle?
Okay.
Okay, Response.
webbook can only call laut http 0 check your webhook allow what
die webhook allow list
machen sie aber auch schwierig wo ist denn die webhook laut list die müsste wahrscheinlich hier
irgendwo sein settings nicht profiles
bin ja atmen von dem ding seit administration configuration settings
Ne, hm, wo könnte das denn sein?
Access?
Ne.
Webhooks.
Webhooks make possible...
Ne, oder?
GTA, wo macht man das?
ach das muss man per environment übergeben
aber chat es wird nicht funktionieren weil das von stia und hat hier
ich kann doch nichts nichts pushen sagt er die pläne application wenn ich ein get request macht
geht auch nicht. Ähm, allow list. Wir machen jetzt schon voll das advanced Zeug wieder.
er erholt
erlaube haus lässt
ok das muss ich übergeben
ok da muss ich meinen gta docker wieder stoppen docker docker brander
was am
GTA
Docker Run
okay
ähm
äh
minus E
Äh, hallo?
Nicht Docker Compose, Alter.
Minus E ist es?
Okay, hier.
Minus E, das da.
GTA Webhook
Und dann
Allowed Host
12268.2.130
Bam
Okay, gut
Schauen wir mal
Da sind wir wieder
Dann pushen
Oh meine Güte ist das kompliziert
Dann gehen wir in unsere App
Dann gehen wir auf Settings
Webhooks
Dahin
Okay
Und jetzt pushen wir nochmal
Zack
guck mal es hat funktioniert es hat funktioniert es geht
er hat es gebaut domains da sollte jetzt q chat
nice so heißt im endeffekt das bürger ausbringt heißt im endeffekt wenn ich immer hier chrome
aber wenn ich jetzt hier hingehe und ich sag jetzt hier drin editieren wir das jetzt da steht jetzt
drin massive high iq string dann committen wir das und pushen das dann heißt das ich drücke
jetzt mal ein paar mal f5 hier gucken wir mal wie lange das braucht public läuft es nicht
da ist es naja 10 15 sekunden her bei der wahl meine ram
ist übrigens neue icons
macht mir so viel cpu last war nichts
das ist das ist mein ramm oder oder die disc die disc ist das glaube ich die hat
es neues alten gekriegt aber die disc macht keinen sinn dass diese schwankt ach keine ahnung
das finde ich aber echt ganz cool
jetzt habe ich lokal bei mir im router umgebogen auf die domain gibt es das überhaupt als top level
oder okay das ist schon mal ganz als völkisch gefällt mir das ist ein bisschen gebastelt
einmalig aber dann geht's ja so was haben wir denn jetzt noch die environment
variablen die brauchen wir nicht mehr weil nixpack nicht funzt
was was kann man da jetzt was kann man da jetzt noch machen
Brauche ich den Watchpath überhaupt, wenn ich doch schon hier angegeben habe bei GTA, dass es dann pusht?
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon.
Dockerfile als Build.
To environments brauchen wir nichts, to mainpoint deployments haben wir nichts.
Preview deployments.
Was soll das sein?
Ah, da kann ich eine Testversion pushen oder so.
Wie ist das gedacht?
Adjust the settings for previous deployments of this update including environmental options
deployment rules.
Ne, das sollte nicht den Autodeploy-Haken ersetzen, glaube ich, weil in den Dokus stand irgendwie drin,
man soll auto deploy anmachen und dann geht es mit dem webhook
das brauchen wir nicht schedules schedule task to run automatically at specified intervals
Okay, da kann man so Sachen machen wie
E-Mails verschicken oder so
Oder Datenbank aufräumen
Oder was auch immer
Backup starten und sowas
Das ist ja mega seltsam
Wozu dann der Watcher? Ich versteh's auch nicht
Der könnte doch eigentlich alle 10 Sekunden mal kurz nachgucken
Im Repo, ob es was Neues gibt
One Expression
Aber es gibt ein paar
Schon ausgewählt
Und definiert
Man könnte ja auch hier einfach ein Bash-Skript ausführen, was im Container drin ist.
Ja, aber, sagen wir mal so, das, ähm...
Wenn man es braucht, dann braucht man es normalerweise wahrscheinlich eh nicht.
Volume-Backups. Aha!
Guck mal, man kann sogar Snapshots quasi machen.
Das finde ich ganz praktisch.
Wenn man sagt, ey, gestern ging der ganze Scheiß doch noch.
Aber machen wir mal, wir machen ein Backup.
Select Schedule
Ne ne, einmalig gibt es da vielleicht
Blub
Destination
Kann das sein, dass ich mir hier nichts auswählen kann
Äh
Ich habe keine Ahnung wie man Docker Volume heißt
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Required, required, required.
Gibt es keine Volumes.
Chronic Expression is required.
Ah, ich dachte, man kann manuell mal eins anschmeißen.
Das ist automatisches Backup.
Logs, Monitoring.
da sieht man dass man nicht wirklich was sieht ok requests beim bmw bmw bmw bmw
machen ein paar requests und gucken ob da was drin steht moment steht überhaupt keine
request drin oder da steht nur cpu usage memory usage die tolling so request kann man gar nicht
gucken aber doof das wäre gerade eine interessante metrik wie viele request darüber gehen
naja gucken wir mal wir machen ein bisschen traffic wild true dürfte jetzt nicht allzu
viel sein aber dann ein bisschen ein bisschen ok jetzt cpu usage haben wir jetzt immerhin
hin schon mal ein bisschen ja und wir haben auch ein paar kilo bei network traffic ja traffic
liefert die metrik das dachte ich mir auch advanced oba
also ein bisschen bisschen was machen wir hier ein bisschen cpu last verursachen wir machen wir
hier mal aus jetzt sollte jetzt guck jetzt geht die cpu last auch klar wieder runter so advanced
was haben hier rana kasten command in container after application initial ist das ist cool das
wenn man fertige container benutzt die quasi nicht von einem selbst sind würde ich mal behaupten ja
da ist ganz praktisch als man da noch etwas machen muss was halt nicht eingebaut ist
ohne dass man quasi ein eigenes container image baut was darauf aufsetzt hat das
prometheus exporter das ist eine frage doch neu
sie nicht so aus
so dann hätten wir das so dann kommt das nächste jetzt ach hier kann man
if you want to persist data in the service,
use the following config to set up volumes.
Ach so.
Okay. Ja gut, die besten
containerisierten Anwendungen sind
stateless.
Jetzt
kommt das nächste. Wir wollen eine
Datenbank. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Das ist das Backend.
Create Service.
Database.
AI Assistant.
Was?
jetzt brauchen wir den kompost file template ach da kann man vor konfigurierte anwendungen
schon reinhauen naja das jetzt also das brauche ich dann bei mir nicht
chrome einfach mal chrome
Ja, da sind ein paar
vordefinierte Docker-Files, die man sich da reinhauen
kann. Theoretisch
gibt es da wahrscheinlich,
ja, hätte es auch gegeben.
Aber das ist eigentlich, was
das lastet. Das würde ich dann für
meine Anwendungen benutzen und
nicht irgendwelches vorgefertigte Zeug.
So,
jetzt probieren wir es einfach mal, Database.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
create service database aus grass ja pg database name test db default postgres database passwort
prominent post 15 create jetzt ist eine datenbank da connection string gibt es
ford.io als nee ich glaube das gab sich die hatten nur gitlab github gitlab bitbucket.de
No such container, select the container.
Logs.
No such container.
Hier läuft die Datenbank jetzt?
Start a Postgres database requires a previous successful setup.
Okay
So einfach geht's dann schon immer nicht
Okay, wie und was und wo
Und
Ja
Das wär jetzt auch zu einfach gewesen, oder?
Ähm
Okay
Äh, wie jetzt?
Wo jetzt? Was muss ich Setup machen?
Deploy?
Ich muss einmal auf deploy klicken.
Jetzt läuft's.
Okay, dann testen wir doch mal.
Dann testen wir doch mal, ob das.
ob die datenbank funzt ja bauen wir doch mal eine datenbank connection hier drin
ein rider auf
checken wir mal ja ja wir trusten trusten allem
Chat, ich hab mal ne Frage.
Warum will der dahin überhaupt sich connecten?
Wie kommt der da drauf, sich dahin connecten zu wollen?
Das hab ich doch nirgendwo angegeben.
Wie will der da hin?
Das verstehe ich nicht
Ach ist das die
Git-Integranz
Hä?
Aber das
Okay
das ist immer magic
ok dann kommt es please start öffnen
so schon eine weile her wo ich das so ich das gemacht habe wir brauchen jetzt ist
er vor entity framework ist es jetzt ist das jetzt installiert ne ost kreis
EF Core Postgres Simple Example
Okay, das brauchen wir. Das habe ich mir schon fast gedacht.
Tag. DB-Kontext, ja. Und das ist hier der Connection String.
Okay, ja.
Macht Sinn.
Ziemlich fette...
Ziemlich fetten...
Schriftdaten haben wir hier.
DB-Kontext?
Was?
Ist das AI generiert?
Ja.
Okay, aber anscheinend will der, dass ich sowas hier mache und jetzt hier Options übergebe.
Okay.
Und jetzt brauchen wir Options.
Ach, beim Registrieren.
Okay.
apptb kontext was da brauchen wir jetzt denkt den connections string hier post
post das muss jetzt ein bisschen anders aber kann kann man den connections trinkt
Moment, man kann den auch bestimmt so machen, oder?
So.
So, jetzt haben wir hier unser Postgres-Gedöns.
Jetzt sagen wir...
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Ensure Database Created oder irgendwie sowas.
App.
das ich kriegst gerade aus dem kopf nicht in ihr services jetzt required service appdb kontext und
jetzt kommt mir wie sein database and sure created so die lied und created machte das jedes mal
aber so konnte man das machen okay schau mal
ob das jetzt
service kann ich kann auch die modifizierte kurs ins ried only ach so
verkehrt umgemacht so schau mal
cannot resolve scoped service
dann weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mal wie es funktioniert
funktioniert.
Wie war das denn nochmal?
Fuck, Alarm.
EF Core.
Ey, ich versuch grad meine
Toilettanwendung zu der Datenbank zu connecten
Ich habe vergessen, wie man das nochmal gescheit macht.
Hier, Kontext. Jaja.
Frag doch einfach die...
Wie ging das nochmal?
Wir haben doch garantiert hier schon mal irgendwo...
...
als service provider
das ging doch so oder adept tb kontext relativ
Das ist nicht so.
Cannot Reself Scoped.
Warum Scoped Service?
Ach so, weil ich das in einem Request machen muss.
Wie viel ging das nochmal?
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Das ist per Request.
Aber man konnte das doch auch beim Start.
Ach, New Scope.
Jetzt weiß ich wieder, was wir machen müssen.
Wir brauchen einen neuen...
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Application Scope.
So ging das doch.
Oh, wie ging das nochmal?
Application Scope brauchen wir doch.
Hier, Create Scope.
Context.
Das da, das ist richtig.
Genau.
Aber create Context.
Create Services.
Create Context.
Create Scope.
Genau, so ging das.
Ich erinnere mich wieder.
Using var Context.
Genau.
Und jetzt kann man sagen,
Service Provider.
Get Required Service.
appdb context hier war context db db ich muss alles hier scope
so genau so ging das jetzt sage ich database ensure deleted und database
and created so jetzt können wir gucken ob die verbindung zur datenbank so war das ja
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich wieder.
Eats.
Format of the
Initialization String does not
conform to specification.
Super.
Also. Achso, ich hab gar keinen
String gesetzt.
Auch gut. Ne, doch hier oben.
Also das ist schon mal falsch.
Was ich da gemacht hab.
Ähm.
Das heißt, wir müssen es in diesem,
in dieser Logik hier
Also, Host gleich
Hä?
Aber der Connection String kann doch überhaupt nicht funktionieren
Der kann doch null funktionieren, dieser Connection String
Das löst doch überhaupt nicht auf
Muss man da vielleicht auch Domains oder so noch hinschreiben?
Das ist Internal Connection URL
Das ist für
Ja das ist für wenn ich die Anwendung deploye
Dann kann man die benutzen
Kann man da von außen
Von außen drauf zugreifen überhaupt
Oder ist das gar nicht so gedacht
Das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so gedacht, hä?
Ne, das ist überhaupt nicht so gedacht, guck mal
Das wird überhaupt nicht weitergeleitet
5, 4, 3, 2
Warte mal, was ist das Richtige?
Das da hier
Ne, ne, das ist nicht erreichbar
Da müsste ja ein Port weitergeleitet sein, oder?
Müsste ich ja irgendwie sehen
hier, 5, 4, 2, 3, 5, 5, 4, 3, 2
auf da, dahin, weitergeleitet.
Das ist nur intern erreichbar.
Okay, das kann man gar nicht
von außen zugreifen, wenn ich das
jetzt...
Ach, hier, external port.
In order to make database reachable to the internet, you must set a port.
Okay, 5, 4,
3, 2.
fast
okay, fast
der ist echt hartnäckig
1.2.1.1.1.1.2.1.0
aber
Aber der Connection String ist ja so falsch.
Das ist ja...
Das geht ja so nicht.
Okay, man muss das anders...
Ja, das suckt aber, oder?
String gibt es da nicht?
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Man darf das nicht komplett angeben.
Das ist ziemlich sackig.
Ehrlich gesagt, dass man das immer umschreiben muss.
also ich brauch haus gleich so sagt port username postgres passwort database test
test db so müsste das jetzt funktionieren so müsste das funktionieren schau mal dort
und run. Zack! Job Database, Create Database. Hat funktioniert. Hat funktioniert.
Ich meine, wir können
eigentlich müssten wir das über eine Environment-Variable
setzbar machen
weil
wir wollen ja
wobei, das ist jetzt eigentlich
hat das nichts mit Dogploid zu tun, ja
wir müssten eigentlich hier
Environment-Variablen
injecten
wo das herkommt weil man möchte ja in der produktion dann andere datenbank url
benutzen also es könnten wir machen könnten sagen zum beispiel options
wie von das jetzt noch mal moment muss mal kurz in mich gehen dort net options
options aber ich glaube so ne bilder
services
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Asp.net Core.
Options Pattern.
Ja, das normale Options Pattern
sackt. Das verwende ich nicht.
I-Configuration.
Genau, I-Configuration.
Ich muss mal kurz checken, wie das
noch mal war das kriege ich das war ich zu selten gibt bilder konflikt connection string ok etwas
was was gibt es configuration jetzt jetzt connection string jeder muss es aber in die
settings rein oder getz das besser von der spezifikation schaden vor jetzt section
Connection Strings.
Ah.
Okay.
Ich will es mal anders ausprobieren.
Wartet mal.
Wie funzt denn das nochmal?
So?
Ah, shit.
ähm
äh
get service und dann irgendwie
Iconfiguration, oh ne ich krieg's aus dem Kopf
dann hin
es ist sowas wie self-hosted netlify
ja genau
ähm
Was konnte man da alles hinzufügen hier?
Service Collection.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie es von...
So, Configuration.
Config.
Geht das so überhaupt, was ich hier mache?
So.
Machen wir mal, was ist hier?
Class.
Connection.
irgendwie app settings irgendwie sowas string post kreis oder hier irgendwie
connection spring irgendwie so und jetzt
new app settings noch mal gucken ob das jetzt hier von config get section
ich bin mir echt nicht mehr sicher wie man das überhaupt richtig gemacht hat schauen wir mal
ob das überhaupt funzt. Also das sollte jetzt gerade nichts machen.
Warte mal, .NET run. Äh, wichtiges...
Bin ich denn hier gelandet gerade? Chat?
Okay, das funzt sogar, weil ich da gebaut habe.
Ähm, so, Blubb.
Blubb gibt es nicht.
Ich muss gerade mal ein bisschen basteln.
Ludelwee.
Lass mal kurz schauen, ob das Funds was hier baut.
Äh, macht der überhaupt was?
Ah, das Funds wahrscheinlich nur.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich mach das bestimmt viel zu umständlich.
Ja, okay.
Configuration Section.
Okay, okay.
So.
Ähm.
Ja, ja.
Ich will erstmal die Environment Variable.
Ich mach das viel zu umständlich.
Aber ich krieg's grad aus dem Kopf immer besser hin.
Ähm, so.
Jetzt muss ich Environment-Variablen
Env ASP.NET Core.
Die musste man doch so komisch setzen, dass die funktionieren.
Was ich probiere ist, ich versuche, dass ich
einen Connection-String bei Environment-Variablen setzen kann.
Dass ich lokal eine andere Datenbank
setzen kann, wie bei DocPloy.
Ähm, Environment-Variablen.
Hier.
Wie funzt...
In welchem Format musste man diesen
Krempel nochmal angeben?
set environment environment variable ja ja ja
asp net core environment
ging das noch mal als bettor von fake
Environment
Mein Gott, machen die es wieder kompliziert, Alter
Wie kompliziert möchte ich es
Bitteschön machen
ich weiß wo ich abgucken kann ich weiß es der fiat champ benutzt ein wein und variablen
irgendwie beim start ja wie setze ich die denn locker feil
und fick moment moment ja champ config cs
ok und wo kommt das wo kommt das her
options weint jetzt schon gut und wie wird das jetzt gesetzt
ok wir fahren mal chat gpt asp
da fährt es nicht
geh weg
ASP.NET Core
get config from
n-variable
easily kann man das
easy kann man das machen
my app settings
aha
so ging das
ok
also
Also, myApp, wie heißt denn die App überhaupt?
Die App heißt...
DogployChamp.
Okay, Export, DogployChamp.
Blub, gleich, 1, 2, 3, run.
Okay, so, hat das jetzt funktioniert?
GetSection
Value
Keine Ahnung, Key
Stimmt, E
Es funzt
Nein, es funzt nicht
Shit
Da müsste 1, 2, 3 drin stehen
Underscore, Underscore vielleicht
Ach, come on, ASP.net
Komm, mach es doch nicht so kompliziert
Das war, ohne Scheiß, das war in Spring Boot wahrscheinlich deutlich einfacher.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie man es setzt.
Da muss man das groß schreiben.
Das doppelte Unterstrich, doch, doch, das muss man auch machen hier.
Aha!
Okay, Chat.
Telekonfirm.
Das stimmt aber so nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so für uns...
Äh.
My Settings 1, 2, 3.
Es funzt.
Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Okay.
Alles gut.
Dann können wir uns diesen ganzen Spaß hier jetzt eigentlich schenken.
Dann brauche ich das hier nicht.
Das, das da.
Ähm.
Ich kann einfach so machen.
Äh.
settings kann man das nicht casten irgendwie was ist denn nur mit kasten
los settings haben wir hier gut
so und jetzt ja blubb hier das ist der connection string connection string
Prozent Heck Dabbel jubel
und jetzt kann man die Settings
man kann die Settings auch die Ach die Moment hätte der Dekker gekriegt jetzt
sind String davon
das will ich doch gar nicht
Gert
um
und Figur Reichen die Kammer noch Kammer doch Karsten irgendwie in
ich so vielleicht sagen geht section
wir basteln jetzt section so
und jetzt value value get value so ging das doch ne
exakt das spätest du teilt ob das von zwar sich da machen
Achso, muss ich vielleicht so sagen?
Get Section?
Sieht wild aus, ja, ich weiß nicht was ich mache.
Das funzt so schon mal nicht, was ich hier baue.
Hat das jetzt funzt?
Ich bin da zu dumm für, Leute.
Okay, scheiße.
Wir machen jetzt einfach Configuration.
Dock, Ploy, Champ, Blub.
So.
Das ist der Connection String.
Oder?
Funzt es jetzt?
Yep. Connection String 1, 2, 3.
Beste hier.
dann drauf geschissen auf dieses ganze ding sondern wir sagen einfach nur als
jetzt sagen einfach nur so sagt jetzt von jetzt kann er sich nicht zur datenbank
connect weil das falsch ist jetzt sagen wir hier export connections train der auch
also irgendwelchen Kunden jetzt Plupp bei uns heißt.
Äh, so.
Und jetzt sollte das
eigentlich funktionieren.
Okay, Funst, Funst, okay, so.
Es ist viel einfacher,
als ich es mir gemacht habe.
Man braucht genau eine Zeile dafür.
Und schon funktioniert's.
Genau, okay,
configuration stopp, blub, heißt unser
Connection String. Das heißt
nämlich auch, dass ich jetzt
sagen kann,
hier drinnen,
ähm, mach gerade mal
hier ein bisschen was zu,
dass ich jetzt sagen kann,
hier drinnen,
wir wollen
Environment Variable
Projekte,
Projects, Backend,
Environment, da kann ich jetzt
sagen, wir wollen
Dogploychamp
Und da wollen wir jetzt die
Internal
URL haben.
Die müssen wir noch ein bisschen umschreiben.
Das ist Funst.
Wir wollen haben
hier
Postgres
das stimmt
database hier, das ist der Host
das ist der Host
Username, Postgres, Passwort
dieses komische Ding, database, test.db
so wollen wir das haben
so, und wenn ich jetzt alles richtig
gemacht habe
dann
sollte das eigentlich
funktionieren, wir können es ja ausprobieren, ob es
funktioniert sagen einfach kontext safe oder wie ging das noch mal ja wir
müssen irgendwas weichern atd kontext wir brauchen hier noch eine records chat
wie auch immer ins id und name wenn man das jetzt richtig schreibt perfekt so und jetzt hätten wir
mal hier wen haben wir hier im chat wer wird geadet new chat data die id brauche nicht die
id moment wie war das mit der id noch mal als das asp.net core das checkt musste man da id
drüber schreiben?
ASP.NET
ASP.NET Core ID
Database
EF Core
ID
Keys, ja.
Ach ne, man muss, es muss einfach nur
ID heißen anscheinend.
Data Annotation Key.
Man muss gar nichts, wenn es ID heißt, muss man nichts mehr drüber schreiben.
So war das.
So, und jetzt?
Ich habe so lange damit nichts mehr gemacht.
Das merkt man gleich.
Äh, List?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Äh, DB Set?
War das DB Set?
Ja.
YouTube Chat Data.
Datas, genau.
DB Set heißt das jetzt.
Falsch?
Achso
Ablick
Okay, Name
Slow
Motion
Der letzte Chat-Tor
So, jetzt fügt er was in die Datenbank ein
Danach delete das wieder
Aber jetzt können wir das Ganze
Auslesen, hier im
Im
Get-Request
Da können wir jetzt sagen, AppDB-Kontext, CTX, AppDB-Kontext, da sagen wir jetzt CTX, AppDB-Set, Where oder einfach alle.
Einfach alle Chatter, die wir haben, geben wir aus.
da passiert nichts.
ToList.
So, Chatter.
Return.
String.Join.
Separator,
Chatter.
So, okay.
Jetzt haben wir hier alle Chatters drin.
Es ist ja nur einer aktuell.
so probieren wir das mal aus ob das hier von zwei stange baut habe ron ruck der hat
er eingefügt hier datenbank gedöns curl localhost port 5111 gibt nichts ach so weil ich safe weil
ich nicht gesaft habe kontext save changes ok nochmal
chat data da sind wir doch das sollte er aber so nicht zurückliefern das ist ja auch verkehrt was
was ich hier mache.
DB-Set.
Select.
Name.
Wollen wir nur haben.
Gut.
So, haben wir noch irgendeinen?
Komm hier.
Ja.
Michael 5 Spilian.
Oder wie er heißt.
Genau.
Oh, never pro.
Kommt auch noch rein.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier
drei Chatters am Start.
Okay, so, Funst.
So, dann können wir es mal ausprobieren,
wenn wir das deployen.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Von der Idee her müsste ich es jetzt
deployen.
der müsste automatisch
So, der müsste automatisch
sich zur internen Datenbank verbinden,
die Sachen reinschreiben und ausliefern.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Schauen wir mal.
Git-Status.
Ich hätte...
Ich bin so dumm, ey.
Da muss eine Git-Ignore eigentlich hin, ne?
Aber Program CS reicht ja.
Hit add Program CS.
Womit?
Push.
So, bam.
Ah, running, running.
Es wird neuer Container gebaut.
Okay.
Äh.
Was genau ist das Problem?
Moment.
Locker Bild.
Also was mich wundert ist, im Dockerfile steht nämlich, steht alles drin.
Der macht auch ein Restore.
By the way, was bildet der da so drei Stunden?
Achso.
Was?
Resource temporary unavailable?
Habe ich zu oft irgendwas gemacht heute?
Bin ich blacklisted?
Ist wirklich kaputt?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Ne.
Ist überhaupt nicht kaputt.
Docker, was erzählst du denn da für Mist?
Docker, bilde mal.
Ne?
Der mag nicht?
Moment.
Ubuntu 16, ja meinetwegen.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ich will mal was gucken.
Mein Docker?
Mein Docker hat Probleme, sich ins Internet zu connecten.
Gab es vorhin zufällig den Kernel-Update?
Und das hat Spack deswegen rum?
Das könnte sein.
Da müssen wir rebooten, dass es funktioniert.
Mein Docker kommt nicht ins Internet.
Das wird es natürlich erklären.
Okay.
Reboot.
Schauen wir mal.
123456.
4 5 6 massive passwort
zack zack depot stock ploy champ run ubuntu ping google.de also man kann es
mit minimalismus auch echt übertreiben alter install ok ok jetzt funzt es google.de gut
also docker bild jetzt müsste es eigentlich funktionieren jetzt funzt jetzt funzt ok jetzt
Jetzt von gut aber warum hat das die blume dann hier nicht funktioniert
Ende die framework autos nord existent
Rebuild
Woher weiß ich denn jetzt dass der
Die Bleu.
Was hat er denn jetzt?
Was will er denn jetzt von mir?
Dockerfile
ist von uns doch bei mir lokal.
Ach.
Du hast recht.
Ich hab's nicht geadded.
Ja, ja.
Lul. Alter, bin ich dumm.
Ich hab nur die Program-CS geedit.
Ja, das erklärt es natürlich, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Okay, ich füge jetzt hier noch einen dazu.
Der Vor-Alfred will da noch dabei.
So.
Add.
Comet.
Beste Comet-Message ist übrigens hier.
Okay, jetzt sollte es aber funktionieren.
Deployments.
Less than a minute ago.
Okay, hat funktioniert.
Hat funktioniert.
Domains.
Da sind wir.
Datenbankstellungsfunst
verbindet sich intern
zu einer anderen Datenbank wie bei mir.
Das ist, das, das,
irgendwie hat das was.
Ich bin mir zwar unsicher, für was ich es
letztendlich verwenden könnte, ja.
Aber an sich ist es schon
echt nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Das hat irgendwie was.
Auch, dass man hier so einfach
Datenbanken aufsetzen kann und so.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an,
wir klicken in Cloud SQL bei Google
eine neue Datenbank zusammen.
natürlich nicht ganz so viel kram drumherum aber es funzt was sagt denn
bei logs
database test db das dort existiert ich weiß weil ich die immer löschen immer
anlege
Warnst.
Hat das eigentlich ein PG-Admin oder irgendwie sowas dabei?
Nee, oder?
Naja, plötzlich, dass es direkt da drin ist.
PG-Admin.
Stockploi.
hier kann man das image auswählen was er da am start hat für die datenbank
cluster settings meine datenbank nicht klastern
Backups?
S3 Destinations?
Moment.
Kann man so ein ganz normales Backup ohne Cloud-Gedöns,
so zum Beispiel einfach PG-Dump in ein File,
das geht nicht das muss muss es drei sein die frage ist er würde man das als unternehmen einsetzen
vielleicht als kleinere software laden aber ich weiß nicht ich glaube dafür habe ich
nicht genug benutzt aber ich tendiere zu nicht die den also erst drei destinations
wertschätzt nicht hinzufügen kam schon noch eigene hinzufügen wo alle wie viele
any other s3 kompatible provider also ich meine viel arbeit ist da auf jeden
fall schon reingeflossen das muss man mal sagen
So, lass mal gucken, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Was war denn hier noch?
Jetzt haben wir unser Projekt, wir haben unsere Datenbank
Wir haben unser Backend
Gut, Frontend brauchen wir jetzt dafür glaube ich nicht
Doch, ha!
Pass mal auf, wir wollten doch hier noch ausprobieren
Eine Springboot-Anwendung, eine Go-Anwendung
Wobei, müssen wir das wirklich machen?
Das wird wahrscheinlich so ähnlich funktionieren
Eine Go-Anwendung, eine Go-Anwendung können wir nochmal
Wir können aber auch den...
Wir haben doch letztens eine Springboot-Anwendung gebaut.
Die können wir doch eigentlich gerade mal deployen.
Hier.
Wo ist er denn?
Der Springboot-Champ.
Oder der Kekw-Champ?
Ich glaube, der Kekw-Champ ist es.
Kekw-Champ.
Moment, ich starte nochmal kurz IntelliJ
und gucke mal nach.
Wir können auch mal eine Spring Boot Anwendung
deployen, ob das so easy tut.
Was hat denn das Ding nochmal
gemacht? Achso, hier.
WebSocket Connections.
Genau.
Da schauen wir mal,
ob Nixpack
ohne Dockerfile,
weil noch ein Dockerfile habe ich keinen Bock
zu erstellen.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, hat die Anwendung doch...
Auf welchem Port läuft das jetzt? Steht das hier nicht irgendwo?
Chat, bin ich blind?
Wo steht denn auf welchem Port die Anwendung läuft?
Sollte das nicht da stehen?
Oder wo war das?
Application Properties?
Ne.
8080?
Ist das default, aber steht nirgendwo?
Oder bin ich blind?
8080, doch hier.
Okay.
Curl, Local, Host.
8080.
Was haben wir für Endpunkte?
Ach, warte mal.
Web.
Ja, da haben wir es.
Okay.
Websocket-Pod 8080.
Dann deployen wir doch mal, das machen wir jetzt,
dann deployen wir doch mal unsere Spring Boot-Anwendung.
It-Status.
Der KQW-Champ.
It-Remote-V.
Das ist das andere, das ist das falsche.
Das ist mein lokales, was ich sonst verwende.
Dann legen wir jetzt hier in unserem Test-GTA noch mal eins an.
Root.
sein in ja okay repository kreieren ihre position spring delz
create
geht remote rm origin remote at origin was will er jetzt
trust wir trosten alles
die benutzen das auch das finde ich cool das ist echt nice also ich habe so nie im business
Enterprise Umfeld benutzt.
Aber
bei mir daheim
habe ich das schon eine ganze Weile.
Und das tut einfach.
Und es braucht nicht
so einen riesen Akt drum herum
wie GitLab.
Habe ich übrigens
committed.
Die Wechsel auf GitLab
Ah, ah, GitLab ist viel
ätzender zu administrieren
So, hier haben wir jetzt unser Repo
Dann schauen wir mal
Gehen wir mal hier rein, DocPloy
Ja, machen wir mal, okay, eigentlich ist das
ein eigenes Projekt, aber
drauf geschissen, okay
Create Service Application
Backend 2
Create.
Was?
Can only start
and end letters.
Meine Güte, die machen es ja schon so kompliziert wie bei Google.
Google brauche ich auch dreimal, wenn ich irgendwas
anlegen will, weil er immer sich beschwert
über Bindestriche, Underscores,
Groß-Kleinschreibung.
Okay, dann heißt das Ding jetzt Backend NG.
Weil die coolen Leute nennen sowas eh nicht 2, sondern NG.
Great.
Zack, Backend NG.
GTA, Select Account, Root, Repository, Springstells.
Moment, kann man da zwei Sachen auswählen?
Ne.
Select Branch, Master.
ja, Autobills können wir uns jetzt erstmal sparen.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob Nixpack funktioniert.
Deploy.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Weil der Chat meinte ja vorhin, Spring Boot und Nixpack easy.
Einfach One-Click und es geht.
ok er macht ganz viele dinger ganz viel java gedönst, ne linux package gedönst
java
ist der kollege von gyra
oder ist Jira nicht written in Java?
Ich glaube schon.
Das ganze Jetbrains, äh, nicht Jetbrains Zeug,
ähm, Atlassian Zeug ist doch,
ist doch auch Java, oder?
Okay, der lädt erstmal das halbe Internet runter.
Irgendwelche Poms, das sieht nach Java gedöhnt aus.
Jason, ja, nicht Jason.
Je sors
Ist das eigentlich fahrend vom material wie sie oder beides hast du sowas gelernt und selbst ich habe informatiker
Systemintegration gelernt
Release version 25 noch zu porten leute nix pack nix pack mich ab das fonds nett
Wir sind zu neu.
Java 25 kam, glaube ich, erst vor zwei Wochen oder so raus.
So, was haben wir denn sonst?
Ich habe keinen Bock, ein Docker-File jetzt zu bauen.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so zur Auswahl?
Railpack.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist, aber wir...
Wir nehmen einfach Railpack jetzt.
Bam.
Railpack
Äh
Macht einfach
Gar nichts mehr jetzt
Deploy, confirm
Ah jetzt
Max kann einfach viel
Auch wenn er es nie zugeben würde.
Bester Chat.
Was ist Railpack?
Railway App.
Railpack.
Ich muss mir nochmal angucken, was das jetzt...
Getting started.
Aber Java kann er.
Java kann er.
Das macht ja schon mal Mut, Alter.
Das macht ja schon mal Mut.
Alles 404.
Aber es scheint zu funktionieren.
Erstmal muss das gesamte Internet runtergeladen werden.
Oh, fuck.
Release Version 25 not supported.
Ist das nicht exakt das Gleiche?
Von der Fehlermeldung wie Mixpack?
Nur dass es jetzt Railpack ist?
Okay, Moment.
Chat, wir sind mal high IQ.
Wir haben noch vorhin was gelernt.
Wir haben noch...
Mix, Pack, Java.
The following major versions are available.
21...
So, kann man das irgendwie überschreiben, die Version?
Nee.
Kann man nicht.
Ach hier.
The version can be overwritten by setting nix.
Packs JDK version environment Variable.
Ja dann.
Dann machen wir das doch mal.
Luca, deswegen machst du ja auch die Ausbildung,
dass du was lernst.
Die ganzen Leute, die immer erzählen,
ach, ich mach die Ausbildung nur, weil ich den Zettel brauche,
ich weiß doch alle schon, sind meistens
die, die am wenigsten Ahnung haben. So.
Nix Pucks, JDK Version 25.
Geht das jetzt?
Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen?
Die Pleue.
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Michael, 5 Spilianen.
Nice.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Hast du gesehen?
Du warst eben in der App mit dabei.
Ähm, okay.
Ähm, warum, warum, warum konnte der eben nicht starten, weil ich in den Enviromance was eingetragen habe?
Nehmen wir nochmal Railpack. Ja, mache ich gleich.
Ich frage mich nur, warum das hier gerade nicht funktioniert hat.
Save.
Neu.
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen?
Warum kann er denn...
Ach, Unsupported JDK Version 25.
Ach so.
Ich muss den Kram ja auch mal lesen.
Railpack JDK Version 25.
Hast du nicht gesehen?
Du warst eben schon dabei in der...
Oh, jetzt muss ich das Ding erst nochmal starten.
Nee, Moment.
Wir können noch hier auf Test App...
Guck mal.
Du warst schon Chatter, bevor du überhaupt da warst.
Richtig, Macher, ja.
25, save.
Und jetzt stellen wir das wieder auf Railpack um.
Save.
Deploy.
Running.
Ahhhh, guck mal da.
Railpack Java.
Nicht Back, Rail.
pack jetzt download oder jdk 25 jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren
ist weil ich auch irgendein application server in java habe ich einmal gehört aber nie glaube
gesehen
sql es dankeschön für den sub sorry falls ich irgendwelche subs übersehen
habe ich mir fällt gerade ein dass ich glaube ich bis vor fünf minuten noch gar
keine subs geguckt habe uralt ist der guck mal ich glaube der ist fertig
exporting layers dauert erstmal eine halbe stunde weil der container so fett
ist gut er hat das halbe internet und java runtergeladen bin mir nicht sicher
was größer ist das halbe internet oder java ok doch die pläne das hat hat
funktioniert leute hat funktioniert okay wir hätten eine domain spring
stells punkt chat punkt container port 80 80 create page not found
bad gateway ok
der container läuft nicht
Hibernate mag nicht.
Hibernate hat keinen Bock. Warum nicht?
Unable to open JDBC Connection.
Ich hab doch gar keinen,
guck mal, ich hab doch hier überhaupt nichts.
Java-mäßiges
Datenbank stellt's mir am Start.
Hier ist doch überhaupt nichts mehr mit Datenbanken, oder?
Nö.
Gar nichts mehr.
Läuft ja lokal auch ohne Datenbank.
Also keine Ahnung.
Ich habe sie in den Dependencies.
Ja, und?
Ist das ein Problem?
Wenn die Library in den Dependencies ist?
Also mein Java-Zeug funzt nicht.
Das restartet die ganze Zeit.
Ne, der kann ja ruhig die false localhost in memory eine Connection bauen.
Das klappt ja hier lokal auch.
Guck, das geht hier lokal auch.
Ohne dass er irgendwie abkackt.
Also mein Springboot, die Springboot-Sache funzt nicht.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keiner Bock
Das zu debuggen, warum es nicht funktioniert
Ich glaube das ist übrigens auch gar nicht mal so schlimm
Das geht ja danach noch weiter
Ich würde sagen, dass das prinzipiell eigentlich funktioniert
Aber
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen crasht
Ja
Also bis jetzt hat die ganze
Nixpacks Railpack Geschichte also richtig gut
Funktioniert
Dachte mir probierens mal aus
Nimmst aus den
Dependencies raus
Also du meinst
Ich soll
Quasi hier in
meinen POM gehen.
Was muss ich denn rausnehmen für Datenbanken?
JNA
muss ich rausnehmen, gell?
JPA
und H2 Database.
Und Postgres.
Glaub ich.
Oder? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
JNA? Was zum Teufel ist JNA wieder nochmal gewesen?
Wozu brauche ich das?
Ah, für mein Native C Library Gedöns.
Okay, daran könnte es aber vielleicht sogar liegen.
Das Lib C und so.
Ja, Moment, das machen wir gleich wieder rein.
Also dieses XML-Verwaltungszeug da in Java ist echt nicht so geil.
Okay, jetzt funzt es.
Wir schmeißen es mal raus.
Comment.
kommt wir schmeißen es mal raus
alles klar dann
ist das spring boot
Keck W, Champ.
Git, add.
Git, commit. Ja, Omega, Lull, Bester.
Push.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Nein, ich hab mich vertippt. Gut.
Was?
Wie?
Be everything up to date.
Kann aber überhaupt nicht sein.
Achso, der Branch heißt anders.
Achso!
Ich hab das falsche gepusht
die ganze Zeit.
Aber ich kann
Kekkel nach Master pushen,
oder?
ja okay das jetzt natürlich sehr eklig aber okay das funst
der im master ist irgendeine ich habe da keine version die pläne die es überhaupt nicht geben
sollte die pläne wenn nochmal neu jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren er muss aber
erstmal wieder das halbe internet runterladen wie gut dass ich auf der
arbeit wenn nur mit c und html zu tun habe c und html das war das selten die
kombination ja alle mussten recht geben es kommt nicht so oft vor
Was machst du, dass du C und HTML?
Bestimmt irgendwelches Microcontroller gedönst, ha?
Embedded-Kram?
Weil ansonsten fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
exporting layers alle meine docker image sind wahrscheinlich so so fett wie lange
es braucht um sowas zu bilden die pläne jetzt schau mal her ich bin mal gespannt spring gut
Das sieht schon besser aus.
Shutdown?
Was?
Okay, whatever.
Ja, das sieht nach Java aus.
Hier, Springstelz.
Web.
das funktioniert also eigentlich hätte ich jetzt erwartet dass es funktioniert aber macht es nicht
nicht.
Das ist funstlich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall
eine Java-Fehlermeldung.
Aber
kann das sein, dass das standardmäßig
keine Websocket-Connections
unterstützt?
Das Traffic,
was davor ist?
Da ist doch irgendein Traffic davor, der Proxied.
Dass der standardmäßig keine Websockets unterstützt.
Das könnte doch sein.
Docploy Websockets.
Vielleicht Port wegmachen.
Was?
Wie?
Was jetzt?
verstehe ich nicht wo port weg machen hier
wenn ich da was ich musste in der container port angeben sonst checkt das ja nicht loks exit
Der beendet sich.
Guck mal.
Der macht hier immer.
Seht ihr das?
Der macht graceful shutdown.
Started on port 8080.
Started.
Und dann sagt er shutdown.
Hä?
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Stopp.
Direkt Feierabend.
Ja.
Der hatte keinen Bock mehr.
Started.
Jetzt ist es started.
Geht aber nicht.
Started.
Port 8080.
Ja.
Er hat so eine typische Java-Fehlermeldung.
Aber Port 8080 geht nicht.
Ne, also jetzt läuft die Anwendung.
Aber Websockets gehen nicht.
Ich wette mit euch, das ist, weil...
der Traffic davor nicht Websockets weiterleitet.
Ey, wie oft ich heute meine IP geleakt habe.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Update Server IP.
Ah, darf ich jetzt endlich mal
da reinschreiben?
Okay, das ist aber sehr nice. Dankeschön.
Reload.
Terminal.
Was ist Space?
also an just images clean all server update traffic additional port mapping
reload ich habe doch vorhin die traffic config irgendwo gesehen die konnte man
doch hier einstellen der traffic filesystem traffic config da muss man
garantiert an lockt da kann man garantiert websocket support einschalten
Traffic Websocket.
Ne, das trage ich da garantiert nicht ein.
Entweder das geht out of the box oder nicht.
Aber anscheinend geht Websockets nicht richtig.
Weil die Anwendung an sich ist da.
Ich krieg diese doofe Java Fehlermeldung die immer kommt wenn man...
Okay die helft von Snett.
also das funzt nicht so richtig
was nach der url
stimmt du hast recht
du hast recht hier muss kein 80 80 hin
schon funktioniert
stimmt du hast recht er geht ja auf port 80 mit der uhr macht es anhand von virtual host ja
ok gut ist alles sehr schön
das haben wir das
haben wir sonst noch jetzt auswahl create services applikation post file
templates irgendwelche fertigen sachen kann mir pg admin
Ach ja, das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so blöd hier einen PG-Admin drauf zu hauen.
Da kann man auf seine Datenbank zugreifen. Das probiere ich jetzt mal aus, ob das funzt.
Wird es den Stream im Wort geben oder wird er gelöscht? Ach scheiß auf IP-Leak,
Alter.
Hol mir nachher eine neue IP und dann ist gut.
Und selbst wenn.
Ich hab keine Ports nach außen hin offen.
das bin ich hier sehend gerade start oder muss ich erst mal sagen die pläne die pläne wo ich
noch einmalig sagen dass das funst jetzt gibt es pg admin stellt der chain wo ist der chain eigentlich
Ich vermisse den Chainlord, dass er seine Ascii-Dickpics postet im Chat und timeoutet werden muss.
Äh, Chat?
Kommt man
Chat
Kommt man da jetzt von außen etwa drauf
Bei mir
Tunnelt das irgendwie, ne oder
Warte mal, wohin löst das auf
Ne, ne, ne, das löst
Okay, das löst gegen eine lokale URL auf
Okay, passt
Ich dachte das hat irgendwas getunnelt
oder so im Hintergrund jetzt.
Okay, das
macht einen random Namen
und löst zu einer lokalen IP auf. Eigentlich eine ziemlich
coole Sache, ja.
Aber noch cooler
wäre es ja eigentlich
Ja, besser wäre es hier
pg-admin
.qchat.
.ajaja
Eigentlich viel besser.
Äh.
Aport 80.
Keckweight.
Können wir das nämlich löschen.
Äh.
Habe ich vertippt?
Was der alles auflöst, lulwe.
Äh.
Ach, hatte ich da mal ein Passwort-Safe laufen?
Auf 2.130.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ja gut.
Aber es löst richtig auf.
Und warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Ist doch genau das gleiche hier.
oder nicht exakt das gleiche hier muss man das jetzt verstehen
exakt das gleiche
verstehe nicht
Test App funktioniert ja auch noch.
Hm, keine Ahnung.
Ja, dann gehen wir eben hier drüber.
Aber das checke ich nicht.
Warum funktioniert das und das hier funktioniert nicht?
Das leuchtet mir jetzt nicht ein.
Ausnahme als Env konfiguriert?
Meinst du?
Aha.
Passwort Leak.
Also ich checke nicht, warum das nicht funktioniert.
aber gut weil das geht ja anscheinend
at new server kann ich denn hier 0
Funktionslos, Connection, Hostname. 192, warte mal, intern? Ich kann doch jetzt hier das interne,
den internen host nehmen test db das da kann ich doch jetzt nehmen
hier ausnehmen sagt username aus kreis der test db passwort passwort hat was
Passwort hatten wir hier.
Save Password.
Save.
Name does not resolve.
Warum?
Warum resolvt er Name nicht?
Müsste das nicht exakt so?
so hängt er einem anderen docker netzwerk jetzt irgendwie 192 168 30 das das okay das
von hier sind jetzt die sachen drin da ist es wieder schnell databases test db
ja tables db set
columns
id
Ja, genau. Okay, das Funds.
Alles klar.
Okay, das
klappt.
Ja gut, warum die Domain immer noch ein Funds,
verstehe ich nicht. Aber gut, dann halt nicht.
Zack, confirm.
Ist aber eine coole Sache, dass man
solche Sachen da mitdeployen kann.
Ich habe gestern
mittels github self hosted runner und hetzer cloud meine eigenen github mit
mehr disk space realisiert weil die gitter zu wenig du hast hier quasi den
eigenen aufgesetzt was denn im kassier quasi eine hetzer kiste und darauf ein
eigen github runner ja jetzt da ist super günstig also meine lieblings kiste
bei hetzner ist preis ist ja also meine lieblings ob das sieht jetzt anders aus
haben die ja die 33 cpu 4 gigabyte ram das sind meine lieblingskiste preis leistungsmäßig cpx 21
8 gb reich dicke wie gegraben ist auch okay für die meisten sachen und drei kerne das ist meine
Lieblingskiste.
Hatten die nicht auch
ARM-Server? Wo waren die denn jetzt
nochmal? Chat?
Oder gibt's die nicht mehr?
Ach ne,
das sind die. Das sind die
ARM64-Server hier.
Ist die überall
auf der Welt gleich teuer? Ja.
Das kommt auf die Location an.
kriegst du ein bisschen mehr RAM
aber das ist meine Lieblingskiste hier
hier kannst du die Location auswählen
ok
also
ich würde sagen jetzt haben wir so ziemlich alles ausprobiert
ich glaube eine Go-App können wir uns sparen
im Endeffekt
und was kann man so auch spart okay was denke ich von doc ploy also
einmal wieder wäre cool er gebe ich dir recht hast hast eine idee für irgendwas
nice singo wir gucken uns mal go generics an ich habe go generics nie benutzt und was ich
habe immer gehört go generics ist in abfac stimmt das sind go generics abfac die syntax ist trash
Ich habe gelesen, sie haben ganz lange gewartet, um Go Generics einzuführen, um es richtig zu machen.
Aber anscheinend hat es nicht so ganz geklappt.
Den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Homebox hat jetzt Bounties, wir können da eins machen.
Ach, du meinst, das wird für Homebox...
Ist Homebox in Go programmiert?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass meine Go-Skills wirklich ausreichen, um irgendwas auf die Reihe zu kriegen, dass es so gut ist und schön ist und getestet ist und dokumentiert ist, dass die das annehmen.
Ihr kennt mich. Ich schreibe keine Comments, ich schreibe keine Doku und ich schreibe keine Tests.
Weil immer alles First Try funktioniert.
Logischerweise.
Error-Free Programming.
Okay, also meine Meinung zu
Dogploy. Ich find's sehr
nice das Projekt. Muss ich mal sagen,
wir haben selten Software hier im Stream,
wo ich mir nach dem Angucken
sage, ey, das ist nice,
Ich habe ja immer was zu meckern.
Mir gefällt das richtig gut.
Mal so zur Abwechslung.
Ich habe selbst, gerade so aus dem Stehkreis, keinen richtigen Anwendungsfall dafür.
Wenn ich was bastle in letzter Zeit, ist es hauptsächlich Microcontroller-Gedöns.
Und da bringt mir DocBloy nichts.
Für Kommandozeilen-Tools bringt mir DocBloy auch nichts.
Also ich habe jetzt nicht so richtig
einen Anwendungszweck für, aber mir gefällt es
richtig gut, wie es gemacht ist
Auch das Handling von den Datenbanken und so
das ist alles
easy gemacht
Wie gut sich das Ganze jetzt schlägt
wenn man da
keine Ahnung, 80 Anwendungen drauf laufen
hat und
30 Datenbanken oder so.
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie es ist mit Updates.
Ob es dann Probleme gibt.
Von einer Version zur anderen.
Keine Ahnung.
Das kann ich nicht...
Stopp.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber insgesamt ist es eine sehr coole Geschichte.
Ich glaube, wofür das richtig cool ist,
sind Web-Entwickler
oder Leute, die gerne
Projekte veröffentlichen.
Also mit
Web-Projekte.
Ist egal, in was das Backend ist.
Für so Leute ist das cool.
Oder wofür das auch cool ist,
dass das, was ja bei den Amis
immer so angesagt ist in letzter Zeit,
so die Side-Hustlen ja alle.
Die arbeiten ihren
no life job bei google und haben nebenbei noch 75 side projects und 15
services wo sie versuchen das nächste ding aufzuziehen mit dem sie passives
einkommen generieren dafür ist das glaube ich ganz gut wobei
da halt auch wieder die frage ist wie gut ist das wirklich wenn du mal ein
service hast der wirklich richtig beliebt ist weil mit skalierung sehe ich
jetzt hier ehrlich gesagt nicht du hast ja jetzt irgendwie docker swarm drunter
wovon ich keinen plan habe da weiß ich aber nicht wie gut das funktioniert also
wenn du mal wirklich ein projekt hast was richtig abhebt dann wirst du
wahrscheinlich das ding irgendwo anders drauf packen und nicht mehr auf den
dog play host wo 40 andere projekte auch drauf laufen also ich glaube sobald das
wirklich ordentlich wuchs braucht ist das wahrscheinlich nichts aber selbst da
man braucht oftmals viel weniger hardware als man eigentlich denkt also
ich kann mich doch daran erinnern mein lieblingsbeispiel ist immer ich kriege
jetzt die zahlen nicht mehr genau hin aber ich hatte mal ein meeting um eine
alten arbeit und da haben die zu uns gesagt bohr das ist ja ich weiß nicht ob
es in wordpress war kann sein dass es in wordpress war ich habe keine ahnung ich
glaube es war ein wordpress wir haben es hier so neues blog oder irgendwas
irgendwie neue wordpress seite und der braunen server für und das server der
bruch richtig power wie recht sind damit ganz vielen zugriffen okay ja okay was
denn? Und mit, ich kann ja euch die
genaue Zahl nicht mehr sagen, ja?
Und da sagt er,
hab ich ihn gefragt, ja, was sagst du denn so ungefähr?
Ähm, was denn, was denn für
Zugriffe? Und da meinte der irgendwie
so, ja, schon ein paar tausend
oder zehntausend.
Aber ich dachte, was? Pro Sekunde?
Und er meinte, nee, am Tag.
Hahaha.
Okay, ich bring euch
demnächst einen Raspberry Pi mit.
Hahaha.
ja 10.000 zugriff am tag ist halt absolut gar nichts also bekommt halt auch schon
mit billig hardware relativ weit ja wenn es jetzt wirklich komplett abhebt ja und
man 10.000 request pro sekunde hat dann kann man sich ja mal was überlegen
und selbst da ganz ehrlich du kommst auch verdammt weit mit irgendeinem mit
irgendeiner Hetzner-VPS oder sowas.
Mit irgendeinem Hetzner-Server.
Ja, genau. 10.000 pro Sekunde.
Je nachdem, was... Ich meine, es kommt
ja auch immer drauf an, was bei so einem Request
alles passiert, ne? Ist jetzt auch noch
nicht der Weltuntergang.
Holst du die Hetzner-Kiste,
die ich vorhin gezeigt hab, mit 3
Kern, 4 Ggramm. Wobei, 4 Ggramm
könnte vielleicht, je nachdem, was das macht,
vielleicht noch ein bisschen knapp werden.
Aber da bist du auch billig dabei.
Ja? Da bist du auch billig
dabei wurde definitiv nicht billig dabei bist ist wenn du diese anwendung bei
keine ahnung heroku oder noch schlimmer bei irgendeiner cloud run mit cloud
functions oder so baust du bist du nicht billig dabei da bezahlst du dann statt
sieben euro bei hetzer bezahlt dann wahrscheinlich 350 euro bei einem cloud
anbieter im monat dafür musste dich halt um weniger kümmern aber ganz ehrlich
So viel musst du bei einem Linux-Server jetzt auch nicht machen.
Also dafür ist es wahrscheinlich nichts.
Aber ansonsten ist DocPloy ein mega nices, cooles Projekt.
Gefällt mir richtig gut.
Muss ja auch mal sein.
Ich kann nicht immer alles schlecht finden.
DocPloy gefällt mir.
DocPloy finde ich richtig gut.
Wolltest du nicht mal einen Sponsored Hetzner Stream machen?
Ich habe schon viele Sponsored Hetzner Stream gemacht, aber in letzter Zeit nicht mehr.
Ich habe auch in letzter Zeit nichts irgendwie da abgemacht oder so.
Also gibt es gerade auch nichts.
Und nachdem ich auch so unregelmäßig gestreamt habe in letzter Zeit, macht es auch keinen Sinn.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht, wie die Webseite abkacken kann, wenn sich alle anmelden.
Weil ganz ehrlich, alle anmelden, was werden das sein?
Wie viel sind alle?
400, 500 Leute?
Wie schlecht muss das programmiert sein, dass ein Webservice bei 400-500 Sachen da in die Knie geht?
3K-Studenten gleichzeitig.
Die sind ja auch nicht zur Sekunde.
Die sind ja auch nicht zur Sekunde gleichzeitig.
Die verteilen sich wahrscheinlich mal über eine Viertelstunde oder so.
Aber selbst das müsste doch eigentlich ohne Probleme funktionieren.
Also ich könnte euch wahrscheinlich den 0815 ServiceIn.net in 20 Minuten zusammenwurschteln, der irgendwie einen JSON-Request kriegt und, keine Ahnung, Kurs-ID und das in die Datenbank schreibt oder so.
In die Datenbank, SQLite-Datenbank.
Sogar mal in der SQLite-Datenbank geht das.
ach, die
Instant, die Inken da
Instant alle innerhalb von einer Sekunde
ein paar Sekunden drauf, ja, okay
dann verstehe ich es, aber selbst das
ist eigentlich handelbar
ja, das habe ich mitgekriegt, dass die Xbox
Game Pass
Sache gecrashed ist, weil die Leute kündigen wollten
aber selbst das müsste eigentlich gut
ähm
selbst mit SQ Lite geht das
Okay, jetzt laber ich irgendwas
Wovon ich keine Ahnung hab, weil
Nicht, dass ich schon mal ausprobiert hätte
Irgendeinen Backend-Service mit SQLite
Und 3000 Requests, die instant reinkommen
Keine Ahnung
Wahrscheinlich stimmt es nicht, was ich sag
Aber ich stell es mir durchaus
Handelbar vor
So
Und ich sag absichtlich
SQ Lite, weil es da mit
Parallelen Sachen immer schwierig ist
Wenn du da eine Postgres
Dahinter hängst oder so, ist wahrscheinlich
Eigentlich gar kein Problem
Ich stell's mir zumindest nicht so schwierig vor.
Vielleicht ist es aber auch viel schwieriger,
als ich denke.
Wollen wir nicht auch mal DuckDB machen?
Ich benutze Postgres für alles.
Postgres beste.
Postgres kann JSON, Postgres kann
NoSQL. Naja, vielleicht
nicht. Naja, aber
du kannst
95% der Sachen mit Postgres
abfackeln, ohne dass du
NoSQL-Datenbrauch brauchst.
Du hast Timescale-Sachen für Timeseries-Daten.
Du hast Volltext-Suche mit TreeCram-Support, nebenbei noch eine ganz normale relationale Datenbank und 30 Milliarden andere Sachen, die Postgres kann, die mir gerade nicht einfallen.
ZeroMQ, ich habe mal mit .NET mich vor Urzeiten zu einer ZeroMQ verbunden, weiß gar nicht mehr für was.
Das war es aber auch.
Cockroach.db, es gibt so viele Dinger.
Ganz ehrlich Leute, Postgres, beste.
95% kannst du easy mit Postgres abfackeln
und ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser
in dem Fall dann
Postgres beste
gibt nichts besseres
und jetzt kommt mir keiner mit Oracle
oder irgendwie sowas
wir haben auch auf den Arbeit Leute der Meinung
sind richtige Anwendungen laufen auf Oracle
nicht auf Postgres
was auch immer richtige Anwendungen sind
Kobol wahrscheinlich
Postgres ist das beste
AranguDB
Von der habe ich noch nie was gehört
Ja Leute
3,5 Stunden
SurrealDB
Das habe ich auch schon gehört
Das Ding
die, sind das die nicht
written in Rust, die angeblich in allen
Bereichen super-placingly fast
und besser sind als alle anderen und jetzt, wo
sie die Features drin haben, die andere Datenbanken
auch haben, sind sie genauso schnell.
Da hab ich am letzten Sing-Weaver-Blog-Beitrag
zugelesen.
Jetzt, wo sie die Features von den anderen Datenbanken langsam, aber
sicher einbauen, sind sie genauso langsam wie die
anderen.
Tja.
Naja
Chat
Ich geh jetzt nochmal kurz in die frische Luft
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart
Plesk
Ich weiß, was es ist
So ein Admin-Panel
Noch nie war es großartig mitgemacht, kann ich nichts zu sagen
Schön, dass ihr alle da wart
wir hören uns chat bis denn im nächsten stream macht's gut zu was mit dem fraser ganz selten
in letzter zeit ja gar wenig überschneidungen gerade was games und so angeht was kein obdor
auch noch sachen spielt ich würde gerne mit dem fabian wieder irgendwas spielen
meinetwegen auch in den web game das spielt ja manchmal so dinger
Okay, bis dann Leute, macht's gut, tschüss